Man, fuck this shit.
We're live.
No, fuck you.
Bro, how do I, how do I fucking, how do I, how do I play
live?
We're live.
How do I skip the tutorial on this shit, man?
Fuck this shit, bro.
I'm so, I'm so done.
Wait, just like that, we're live?
Yeah, just like that, we're live.
Yes, we said no waiting room.
We're live.
Everything's live now.
All right, how are we going to start the story of why our PR
is late?
So RPR couldn't get the store preferences correct.
Wait, my OBS is fucked.
Wait, what?
You're streaming your POV as well?
What, am I not allowed to do?
No, you are, but I'm just surprised you are.
Okay, so we had a lot of issues getting Zeller the game.
We had a lot of issues with that.
Yeah, no, I had it all prepared.
okay come on guys back me up on this i was prepared right
you would not know i was and then technical difficulties 10
minutes before this 10 minutes before we were supposed to
start you were like i just finished the tutorial no that was
30 minutes before the stream please be please did sound all
like happy oh i finished tutorial guys yes that's what i'm
saying and then suddenly know had some technical
difficulties so I was like oh shit I need to re-download the
game right yeah yeah and then yeah but then I apparently I
had to buy it again and stuff and then stall preferences and
region lock and all that so I ended up spending like $200
trying to buy this game and get it again it did not work by
his steam gift card yeah exactly it didn't work so what
happened out from behind you after that yep he's like you've
been trying to purchase too many times you can't buy nothing
i was like what the am i gonna do so then finally i had to
take it into my hands and then i actually made an entire
email address new account i purchased it on that account and
then finally be able to play how did you do it god i say
thank god you exist bro and then and then han named it
zeller is stupid as the account well you're gonna look at me
and tell me that i'm wrong am i wrong you're not right
you're not right all right how do we play this guys what do
we use the steam code give me a steam code oh yeah join via
right because this is a brand new fucking account we have to
make after all that stupid shit that fucking goes through i
i can't handle you only dinner tonight okay it's not my
fault man honestly two times because it was expensive i guys
i just need to know this is zeller while more tamed than
what he was off stream oh yeah let's just say let's just say
a couple guns would be handed out you guys know zeller this
is zeller while he he has he's restrained right now oh yeah
you know me you know how it is all i'm saying is you're
paying for dinner bro i don't go off what did you do man you
did nothing i cooked the fault for you i know you didn't he
took the fault for you for like 30 minutes before this guy
talking about bro hey i'm gonna go live too i just oh you
weren't live you went live what happened my obs reset it
gave us i guess we got tired you guys sent a friend oh yeah
let me uh yeah i forgot the rpr is the lobby leader so yeah
no you can just join via like friends list because that's
what i did all right let me add to now i have like three
seller accounts on here yeah The fact that he named all of
them Zeller too Zeller, Zeller, Zeller, Zeller Yeah, because
they're all new accounts, bro.
He's the suss one.
Okay, I'm going live.
All right, what do I do?
How do I join via friend list?
What do I fucking...
You're right.
You just like go to the friends and then do join game.
Socials.
This one.
Ah, friends.
I have zero friends.
What the fuck, man?
what's new what do you mean we all had it too we all had it
too uh how do i oh this one joins squad there we go nice
let's go yeah fucking ow all right my cam is my cam is on
and i'm not bald there we go it could be a wig bro you could
have got a wig bro bro let's go to like your open voice bro
y 'all gonna use open voice let's use open voice it'll be
funnier it'll be funnier because i can't scream i'm gonna
get kicked out well that's your problem bro you're my
problem man you're my well sucks to be you bro hell divers
doesn't even have proximity voice we can all hear each other
regardless what okay that's yeah okay how do we turn it off
then how do we turn this shit off options is it audio uh
voice chat this one disabled bro guys rpr is a super citizen
he actually paid for this game more than look at this guy
look at this guy he was like flexing his paid cosmetics to
us oh yeah guess what i paid 200 for this fucking game oh
yeah what is not a super citizen paid cosmetics rpr i'm a
free player can you buy for me too come on Yeah, look at us.
Look at my army.
I'm just a baby.
I'm just like Ham looks like like like how you guys do the
emotes.
Did your clothes.
Oh, it's beef.
How do you guys do emotes in ship?
You were in the tutorial.
What do you mean?
Uh, what tutorial?
I skipped it.
You were in two tutorials.
It's beef.
All right, let's go kill some bugs guys.
I want to shoot them off.
Yeah, no, we should actually, no, let's not do the robots.
I feel like Zillier's gonna kill us.
Robots?
No, no, no.
There's no robots in this game.
There's no robots.
Bro, dude, dude, dude.
Trust me, yo.
Robots and like me, it's like a duo, you know, dynamic duo.
It's like sandwich and mayonnaise.
I'm the mayonnaise.
You're doing it.
Hey.
There's no one liberating this planet.
You're doing wonderful, buddy.
You're doing wonderful.
He's doing great.
Liberating right now.
bro bro bro come back got me up homie oh electric wheelchair
got me up homie we got this where are we doing rpr which way
oh my mic is wrong yeah thanks yeah where are we going rpr
where are we We're going in level nine.
Level nine is a baby.
Let's go.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, I'm not.
You're also a baby.
I am a preteen right now.
Excuse me.
Excuse you.
I'm preteen.
Gosh, in my preteens, I was playing Neopets.
Oh, shit.
Well, how about now?
Got my job.
Neopets adventure quest, club penguin.
Club penguin.
That shit was five.
I was a waiter in the pizzeria man dude the pizzeria dude
they're like these like little fucking fluff balls remember
yeah whatever they're called I was ruining it I was ruining
the dates at the pizzeria the fucking snowboarding shit I
remember the card game they had like baby love game remember
the dojo card game that they had okay game I remember the
fucking the sled races bro yeah no sled races and there was
like this dojo fucking card game you could have fucking play
i forgot what it was called it's card i don't know card
jutsu was it card jutsu i don't know i was golden at the
game bro yeah secret agent did rpr is too old he doesn't
know this kind of stuff yeah he is he doesn't relate to you
guys you used to play like fucking tetris
playing second life while we were playing club penguin this
guy getting the fucking hell pot bro i'm getting in oh i got
this one i got the all the way to the right side i'm trying
to get us in the game they're just flaming me what the is
this all right we pick our gear okay i'll take an auto can
all right i only have three stratagems um what the fuck i
have offensive supply
I got with the supply then.
Fuck it.
I'll take a...
Oh, wait.
I have two.
I'm ready.
Sounds good.
Okay.
It's all right.
RPR and Han can carry us.
They have the actual good stratagems.
No, come on.
We're a team.
I'm there for moral support.
Me too.
Zeller, Zeller, Zeller.
You don't want any of those red stratagems.
You don't want any of those red...
That's all he has.
That's the thing.
That's the fun.
I'm a clicker.
How do I unclip it?
No, no, no, no, keep it, keep it, keep it, it should be
fine.
No, you're so fucking dead.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, I know what he means.
No, just, no, it's okay.
He doesn't even remember how to activate his strategy.
No, I do.
It was like the code shit.
It's like the beep, beep, beep, beep.
That shit, right?
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Just when you throw it, just at least like, let us know.
Okay.
Bro, if you didn't say that, now you He's definitely not
going to let us know.
What do you mean?
I'm a commander, yo.
You're a cadet.
We're both cadets.
No, Kibur is not ready.
Let's go.
Wait, I did.
Oh, I am ready.
Let's go.
Let's kill some bugs.
Bro, you know, when I was like fucking seven or six years
old, we were fucking blockbusters, right?
And my dad was like, hey, let's get this movie thing.
It's really cool, you know?
And I was like, oh, yeah, what is it?
You know, Starship Troopers, right?
That shit traumatized me when I was a fucking kid.
Dude, like, there was like this fucking...
There was like this guy who was, like, in the plane, like,
we're gonna go kill him!
And then he gets his fucking legs chopped off.
And I was like, I was like, what the fuck is this?
I went to my dad's room, right?
When I was, like, super, super young.
He was watching Starship Troopers.
I had no idea what it was.
I walked in.
Someone's brain was getting sucked out by the monster.
Okay, that part was not scary.
The brain sucky...
What do you mean?
fuck he was not that scary all right calling my machine gun
what's this what do we do with this what do you mean what do
we do with this oh oh oh what do you mean what's going what
is it shooting oh is that look me is that look come on come
here come here come here come here come here right right
here check it out take it out ready how is that ready ready
what are you doing what are you wait who's who i'm d2 me his
tea bag in me i request reinforcement okay x4 is seller at
least we know now i request reinforcement all the trouble
you've given me oh i'm back that's for the 200 oh my god
that's great that's for the 200 dollars 200 what do you mean
i pay 200 okay where's the guys zeller landed on me and I
died.
Okay.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Ah!
I'm fucking silly!
You were in front of me!
That's not my fault!
You walked in front of my bullet.
We!
Oh my god!
RPI help us!
RPI.
And I think he's ASK.
How did I land on you?
That's your fault for- RPI.
Whoa.
You landed on me.
I saved you.
you you killed me i also say you can't deny that i got you i
got you i got you oh please don't get me please please do
not get me i got i i got a reload apparently okay oh yeah
don't like i'm gonna if you reload you lose your ammo in the
reload so don't don't reload unless you have to okay someone
collect that Where's my machine guns?
Wait, what?
Liberator.
You lend, you lend on Han and then you kill Roki Roki.
Ah!
What the fuck is that?
That's grenade!
What the fuck?
This is...
This is gonna go very well.
No, I didn't.
Remember my rodent chat?
I was like, I think Zona's gonna kill us the most because he
just finished the tutorial.
I'll just fucking go right up on the I'll just fucking come
on if I'm not near you guys I can't kill you guys right yeah
go after the sunset I got you I feel like you you're gonna
find a way you're gonna find a way these guys look like
fucking crabs bro you gotta stop bro we gotta stop we gotta
nice nice nice nice nice we're so good we're so good oh big
guy bro there's fall damage Wait, shoot his butt, shoot his
butt.
I'm shooting, I'm shooting the ass!
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
Beep, boop, beep.
I did something.
Ah, great supply here, guys.
Oh, I got you, I got you.
Oh my god, please do not throw this at us.
Please don't throw this at us.
Wait, is this guy dead?
We need 10 more.
We need to kill 10 more.
I think I remember this guy.
Isn't this guy the guy that comes out of the fucking dirt
and like ate the girl in half?
Oh, this is like legally dist- Oh, what?
You shot me!
What do you mean?
I didn't shoot anything!
I don't know what you're talking about.
You have no proof.
You're not streaming.
You don't have proof.
Guys, I got you.
Guys, I threw something.
I threw something.
It's fine.
We're fine.
I told you I threw it.
I told you I threw something.
Okay, what do I do with this?
Hello.
I'm coming back.
Oh, that's a free gun.
I don't know who's gun this is.
guys look at us we did the mission we did it we did it nice
let's go home guys yay i was cooking flawless oh my god oh
i'm cooking look someone needs to flip that should he lens
on hand right next to me takes out takes up his outer cannon
and she was what huh guys we did our first mission i'm so
happy i'm so happy we picked the mission where we don't have
the least spot thank fucking god thank god everyone in this
office with me man holy shit okay let's see who had the
least death it doesn't show that it doesn't show that
yeah look at us we got five stars guys We were cooking.
Holy shit.
I feel like Zeller did not deserve to level up.
Dude, I had the most experience point.
You know what that means.
We all get the same experience.
We got the same experience.
It's just because you're level one.
Well, it's a thought that counts, you know.
It looks like I got more.
Look at that default.
Look at us.
No, no, no, no.
I'm not default.
I'm clapping.
That's different.
Let's see, friendly fire damage, $25.
Look at the stats right now.
The stats, okay, let's see the stats.
Doki died four times.
I wonder why.
Dude, I have more kills than Doki.
Oh yeah, I was dead like 80% of the fucking round.
No, that's just, that's just, that's a youth problem.
Sorry guys, I'll, sorry, I tripped and like, fell everything
was i didn't even use a stim bro i didn't even use a heel
you know sorry guys i tripped and fell accidents happened we
are 40 minutes late for this first game literally being a
movie someone needs to just make a clip of that entire first
game from his tov bro 2 583 friendly damage you did more
damage on your team than the bugs hell yeah i'm going i'm
fucking going in i was like pressing some random buttons
like what's this and then i threw something i was like what
the fuck is that and then it like started going up i was
like that's a fucking grenade hey guys i threw something i
threw something everyone's fucking good bro i don't think i
don't think zeller will i don't think we should take zeller
to the dude leave it to me there's no way there's no way
we're gonna survive robot land i'll cook now you guys now
chat can tell that like i was not the problem that we're
like here like look what he's doing in game like you guys
think he can handle steam man i had it already and then dude
i count problems okay i think rp is a little low in volume
yeah just talk louder and you're We can maneuver the pawn.
I'm gonna get kicked.
Talk loudly.
Alright guys, this time we're a team, right?
Yep, totally.
Ah!
Me too!
Yeah, totally.
Watch your back, Zeller.
Watch your back.
I'll kill you guys, don't you worry.
What the fuck is this?
Am I louder?
Hello?
Oh, I'm in the auto cannon.
Okay, can you guys to hear me yeah we can hear you what the
is that it's it's what are you guys all throwing oh it's a
machine yeah what happened hey guys i'm dead what happened
they have supplies hey guys i'm dead what happened
Yeah, I'm back, bitches.
Why?
Look, that was not my fault.
You were a casualty.
That was not my fault.
What do you mean it wasn't my fault?
You should have known that one.
I got a free machine gun.
But you should have known.
That was my name and my own business.
Somehow I only got team kills more.
So I'm really good.
Where's my machine gun?
I lost it.
I died.
oh i did thank you did someone take my auto backpack oh i
did i have everything you're gonna have to reload me later
what how do i reload you okay here take this uh bro we
actually take the machine gun i got you machine gun here's
your machine where is it where's my machine gun yeah you
guys coming i'm gonna i'm gonna do the objective big bugs
yes nice my machine i gotta reload guys i'm I couldn't get
my machine gun!
I couldn't get it!
I need to come back.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
You're dead again?
Wow.
You're pretty shit at this game, ghosty, aren't you?
Oh, yeah!
Where the fuck's my machine gun, Zeller?
Because he died twice, I guess I have to take it in my own
hand.
RPR, I got your six.
Oh, I found it.
There you go, I got it.
Don't worry, we're helping now.
Yo, it's so fucking sandy, man.
It's pretty sandy.
RPR, raise your volume.
You're still...
Hello.
I got you guys, I got the machine gun.
Wonderful.
And he's dead.
Yeah, I think he's dead, guys.
I think I get my ammo back at least.
Can you guys see anything?
I think he's dead, guys.
I can't see shit.
There's a sandstorm.
It's a little rough.
This is a little rough.
Who chose this thing?
Welcome back.
I can't see anything.
Where do we go?
uh let's go guys i have the ultimate weapons i swear to god
if you're gonna throw this i swear our this our powers are
standing stills earlier our peers standing still i'm just
getting my audio is it better now oh yeah that's a lot
better actually yeah i got the ultimate i got my ultimate
with me guys go for your ultimate i'm on the throw it oh
okay you want me to throw the No no no no no don't do that
don't do that.
We don't need that.
Oh no no no no I threw it through it through it.
It's coming!
Yes the orbital strike!
Two!
One!
Boom!
There we go.
Look at him.
He's learning.
He's actually learning.
They already all died though you guys killed a lot of dead
bodies.
No you did that.
You guys did not make my ultimate worth.
You guys wasted it.
What do you mean you did that?
need to kill all of them no no no that was all you that was
your bomb yeah totally all you guys letting him i'm gonna
bomb you guys what did we do we literally i picked you up
you kill them all you kill them what do we do oh no i'm
reloading do i i have to give you moral support i gotta stop
reloading this gun wait rpr what do we do rpr i don't know
this objective you're the super citizen i'm signal
strengthening there we are you doing the puzzle i can't see
it because you guys are sitting here thanks guys thank you
that really helps citizen rpr you should be able to know
what to do yeah yeah that really helped guys thanks thanks
no problem i'm glad we're i'm glad we're helpful guys all
right um wait do you guys want to like do everything or you
guys don't do the main objective only we should teach we
should teach zeller how to play this so we should do
everything what happened
how is how are you guys dead all the time we let zeller cook
cooked a little bit too long let's just say wait how did you
do that how did you do that f f f f f f no it's my machine
go he's coming back why was it always me why is it always me
we literally kicked his ass we're gonna fail this mission
i'm gonna steal somebody's gun whoa this is my railgun now
Mine.
These small crabs.
Where's my railgun?
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
Oh, something ate me.
No, please.
We're fine.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
She's dead, bro.
It's okay.
We can call him back.
I don't have a railgun.
I got you.
Wait, I don't know a railgun.
Taylor is so lucky that this is unlimited reinforcement.
No, it's not real nine reinforcements.
No, no, it's unlimited.
It's what are you guys talking about?
It's unlimited.
I got the grenade.
Leave it to me.
No, no, no, no.
You got the grenade.
Boom!
Who keeps giving me grenades?
Okay.
Nice, nice.
I killed him.
No, you didn't.
There's still bugs in front of us.
What do you mean, Zeller?
Well, not all of them.
I didn't say all of them.
Okay, I killed one.
There you go.
I'm so proud of you.
What out of a- look like roblox the one out of a hundred
bugs in this island in this in this planet oh um what oh my
gosh oh no guys we have dead teammates i stood in front of
rpr's ray gun we're good we're good we're good we're good
nice that's where you died yeah i stood in front of the oh
acid he spat acid on man okay oh no where's the railgun
that's still from RPO.
Wait, don't you stole the railgun?
Do you get back?
I do!
I'm back!
She's stealing my railgun!
Wait, wait, yeah, I want good weapons too, what's the good
weapon?
Wait, it doesn't even have ammo!
What are you doing?
The sample container, I got the sample container!
Nice.
You're 1 HP, I'm gonna steal his human.
you what's this oh i got something cool yo
bro bring us back bring us back it's okay we have i got the
rail gun guys i got the rail gun it's okay guys we have if
you rub my fucking back i'm gonna die i'm gonna die maybe we
should just do the regular objectives because i don't think
we can do the extra ones no we can do it i believe in us
we're gamers we're gamers you you literally played 10 hours
of hell divers 2 yesterday are you trying to say you can't
do it are you trying to say you're not a gamer hon is that
it wait i think i'm op at this game oh shit something's
hitting me oh wait where do we go up here where do we go
you're you're supposed to tell us where to to the main
mission because there's just no way we're gonna do anything
else yeah you're not getting the relevant what do you mean
okay eventually i got one though i got one though eventually
we're gonna get it i'm scared of what if okay now how do you
use the rail gun you just you shoot it like any other gun
zeller what do you mean you have to reload it what's you
should have bullet he's doing great so you should a bullet
press r should a bullet press r oh let's do this oh supplies
my teammate my stamina is so low i can't run anymore what's
this wow what oh ow ow ow bro you guys are like bullying
babies that's up that's watch out watch out watch out nice
good luck guys i'll be reloading my eyes Oh, hey, there's
more grenades here.
Okay, so with railgun, you shoot this guy's legs, not his
legs.
Zeller, you can reload the grenades here.
Because he breaks the armor.
Oh, grenade?
No, I have four grenades.
There's grenades in the fucking area.
I have a lot of grenades.
Wonderful.
That's what he means, more grenades.
There we go.
No way.
You shoot his leg twice at railgun, and then it breaks the
armor, then you just shoot the leg until he dies.
How come Zeller gets to have a railgun, and I can't?
You can have a railgun here.
Can I?
There you go.
Yay!
I got fed!
Also, I'll just, I'll have you both know you both stole that
railgun from me and the roller dog and you will die
eventually when I have enough.
Do you want one too?
I want a rubber dog.
Do you want some ammo?
Do you want some ammo real quick here?
wait we're getting glam i'm so down so happy i have a rail
gun now yay yay yippee
what's this explosive barrel oh my god oh no do not hit it
no i got it i got it i got it yo no no
hey uh we don't need to reinforce him do we wait i can't
steal his railgun where's his real true where's his real
good already took his real gun how many times do you want to
take it as many times as i can come on in this is called
bullying we have two reinforcements bullying if i'm also a
baby we have two reinforcements and then oh you tried Didn't
you?
What?
Try what?
What give me try?
Try and your best.
That's what you're doing.
Hell yeah, you know it.
You know what she did.
What the fuck?
What are you guys talking about?
You didn't do anything.
You survived.
Here, Zeller, take this.
Okay?
Wait, I'm cooking.
I'm cooking.
You can have this auto cannon.
Look, Zeller, look, look, look.
I'm going to throw a nuclear bomb.
Look, look.
Huh?
what are you gonna do oh oh oh oh what's that eagle oh oh
wow whoa whoa it's all right we can have a little radiation
so what's so special about that that's pretty cool right
it's a nuclear bomb oh any more it's 500 kg let's order more
i can't it's cool dog thank you wait you can technically
have like unlimited nuclear bombs what's this interact what
are you doing huh why are you so slow oh why are you so i'm
nearly dead i gotta heal myself we lost 25 points bro he's
not real no no no we're escorting him professionals it's
fine we're fine i broke him nice i forgot there's fall
damage again He's not a real human being.
Let me cook.
Yeah, I'm cooking.
Okay.
Sorry, I stint.
Go click those buttons guys.
We need more civilians.
Civilians.
Where do we press?
What do we do?
I love killing civilians.
It's okay.
Don't kill the civilians.
They're not real people anyway.
Yeah.
What about a leg shot?
Hey, how about a headshot for you?
You won't.
What if I railgun you?
What do we just slap him?
We should slap him.
Yeah, I am innocent.
He can just heal up.
We have unlimited reinforcements, remember?
Are you running?
Are you trying to run away from us?
Are you...
I just see him try to, like, serpentine.
He's like, he's like running in an S formation.
Bro, you have no stabbing.
up bro bro you're no stamina
that's okay we're fine see jack good job we're doing it
right easy easy easy easy so easy how many civilians are
there why are they all trapped i'm not for us to kill bro
now chat's lying to bro you fuck all of you what did i do my
you damn it's fine we didn't be late bro why were you late
rpr none of us were late okay it was just technical oh yeah
so now that your brain was freaking that works that works
great for you you're a bold man l plus ratio damn where did
you get that wig rpr it's pretty nice i'm not the bold one
land is the problem Let's go Where do we go now?
Where do we go?
RPR is super citizen.
Come to me.
Okay.
Alright.
Where are you?
Dang, these turrets are broken.
Yeah, don't stand in front of it.
No, no, no, no!
What?
What did you do that?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why did you do that?
Wait, I broke my neck because he passed me in the air.
Bro, did you see how far I flew?
Holy shit, man.
I flew.
Bro, where are we?
By the way, the next person who dies can't come back for two
minutes.
So use that information as you will.
You hear that, Zora?
Stop killing people, man.
Use that information as you will.
Let's go extract.
Why do we extract?
Yeah, just...
Yeah, there's a giant bug following us from behind.
He's just...
Not anymore.
He's still there.
What do you mean?
He's dead.
Nice.
All right, guys.
Let's actually extract because we have no lives.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
Hey, baby, girl.
Show, show, show, doki, that's show, doki.
Doki, doki, doki.
I saw it.
Hey, drop me like your friend.
Hey, yo, baby girl.
Hey, yo, what's up, baby girl?
Hey, yo, I found one of these.
Oh, God.
No, no.
Like, I'll run into the monsters.
I'll run into the monsters with this.
Okay.
I will be the sacrifice.
All right.
We believe in you.
Just let me.
We have no lives.
No, no, no, we do.
We do.
We have one more.
I gotta like, I gotta get some- Wait, just a bug behind you,
just a bug behind you!
We'll do this, we'll do this!
Me guys!
Me!
What?
We're no sacrifice.
This is not fair.
Seller, thank you for sacrificing yourself for the con.
Yeah, for like one cockroach.
What?
Hey, a bug's a bug!
Seller, a bug's a bug!
I can't believe it.
This is a scam.
Two seconds.
This is what you wanted though.
Thank you for your- you did your part, Zella.
You did your part.
You're a great asset to the company.
This is a scam.
I think the worst part was that bug didn't even die.
Guess what?
I am not.
Hey, welcome back!
Joining the fray.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh!
let's go oh they are oh wait where is the extraction watch
out watch out watch out don't worry oh yeah leave it to mr
zeller bitch uh-huh no there's a there's an orbital strike
oh there's rockets here oh wait there's rockets here alright
there's an orbital walking barrage in one second uh you guys
can pick up a rocket you stuck him with that then he's on me
no bro you're alive why are you panicking why are you so
scared you're alive look at me cook don't hear him go i
dropped the orbital thingy i'm so proud of you oh my god
he's learning he's learning how to use dragon rock why is
there It's okay guys I'll know how to use it.
Rocket launcher Nice!
We did it!
We got them!
We got the nest!
Wait, why is there a floating rocket launcher here?
We can take it.
Yeah, you can take it.
You have one- Hell yeah!
There's only like one shot though, isn't it?
Yeah, one shot's enough.
Who are you gonna shoot?
Who are you gonna shoot, Stellar?
A tank, it says anti-tank.
guys guys i don't want to bunch up together right now i
don't mind the bunch up next to you guys where's the big guy
come on show me the big one it's dead he's dead oh what the
fuck i'm you're gonna respawn resupply oh yeah okay i said
we can you know we have one more if you want to respawn yeah
that's that's for zeller in like three seconds i don't like
how zeller's walking around with it me too i'm not gonna
kill it i haven't killed anyone today yet yet what are these
like shiny he hasn't done it yet we killed us seven times in
the first edition there's like shiny fruits over here oh
yeah pick it up pick it up no i'm just running i gotta get
to the shuttle
two minutes okay okay
don't worry we should do it you're gonna get to use your
rocket rocket launcher now hell yeah this is it this is the
time i really want to shoot you right now but i'm not going
to how do i put this down okay like that yeah that work oh
there's a rail gun rocket launcher time hey look i'm feeding
the kids by throwing their shoulders it's a real gun wait
the the sentry guns killing everything i don't even have an
opportunity to choose this i'm gonna nuclear bomb that's
like wait which side oh i'm hiding i'm hiding all right i'm
gonna i am going to send in a cluster bomb right here
they're here my my boom you didn't even kill him no it's not
he killed me I'm dead too!
Oh no!
Oh my...
Wait, do we...
Do we lose?
I'm in.
It's up to you!
It's too far from extraction!
I'm running!
Oh, he's just...
I will save everybody!
We have 1 minute 30 seconds!
Ah!
why did you throw rpr i didn't i i pulled in a mortar but
you guys stood next to the animals so you exploded we all
died bro i was holding on to the gasoline tank and walking
to the big dude okay listen it's not i can't i can't believe
rpr through that i can't believe i can clutch or kick yeah
clutch or kick hot oh bro this seems like a nightmare bro i
can't even fucking spectate him i'm like looking at my own
dead body oh okay look at that movement shit hey are you
kidding me there's two of them no no he has he's fine he's
fine oh look at the shadows landing shadows landing live for
45 seconds so you can slowly bring each of us back you're so
greedy no it's gonna deduct yes it's gonna deduct points you
don't want them to You don't want the points to be deducted!
You just have to live for like six more minutes or like four
more minutes.
Yeah, just live for six more minutes.
It's so easy.
It'll be so easy.
We're smelting.
Yeah, it's nothing.
Why is he still living?
Just more minutes.
How are you guys spectating it?
I'm just looking at my own dead body.
Me too.
What?
I don't know.
I'm spectating it somehow.
That's okay.
No!
Wait!
Are you dead?
Did you just leave?
No, he died.
I have no idea how I died there.
I was so far behind my thing.
I'm on solo.
Bro, I guess we gotta kick him.
He didn't clutch.
To be honest, like, Zeller kind of spent, like, 18 of our...
Yeah, I didn't do nothing.
Worth-wild sacrifice.
Let's see the stats and let the stats talk for himself.
us to look at the stats i don't think you guys do realize
they love discord right i leveled up are you guys do you
hear me yeah we can't oh wait wait what happened to what
happened to haunt oh he'll come back you guys should watch
your kick and he kicked himself he actually kicked himself
he's just taking a share he actually kicked himself he
couldn't use for him to go take Let's look at stats.
Let's see, let's see Zeller's stats.
Handed 4.1k.
Friendly spy.
We hunted 4,000.
Bro, hunted 4,000.
Look at my accuracy.
Yes, because I was, I had like the, I had the unfortunate
circumstances of being next to Zeller.
So that I got killed as well because I was right next to
Zeller.
well that's your fault wrong place wrong time dumbass bitch
that's your fault not mine how is that my fault you're right
I should never stand next to you I'm never standing next to
you again now I can kill her and she won't know it's me
because I'm far away what the fuck do you mean you're gonna
kill like Han and RPR if I stand next to them well I guess
that's that then Holy shit, how the fuck did Han do 4,000
friendly fire?
How?
I think he killed the Zellers like 15 times.
I only died 10 times, man.
It says here, I only died 10 times.
Wait, Han actually kicked himself out of the group too.
Wait, how are you back?
Han, you did 4,000 friendly fire damage, Han.
What the fuck?
He was so crazy.
Honestly, deserved.
It was fine.
Oh my god.
Wait, we unlocked hard difficulty, guys.
i'm on hard now oh yay hard that's guys i think we can do
hard difficulty i think we can do it not gonna go great guys
no i think we can do it i think we should we should show
zeller the the robot land yeah robot let's go yeah yeah he
wants to see the robots if we're going on hard mode then we
probably need like a super special team name right what's
your team name what's it to me yeah yeah rp i finished that
sentence what he's saying he's saying you're getting hard
what i'm just i have no idea what you're saying wait aren't
you on twitch so that people can clip that exact moment of
what you just said you can clip on youtube too all right oh
it's the creek it's time for the creek The creek!
Here, let's try robots.
Are we doing the robots?
Yeah.
Right?
We're doing the creek, right?
Is this the creek?
Oh, is it the creek?
No, this is Poplix.
Why not the creek?
Are you a coward?
Where's the creek?
Choose the creek.
Where is the creek?
I don't know.
I'm not the super citizen.
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
That's what's going on.
Let's go to the creek bro Oh, she doesn't know about the
creek.
We lost We lost it.
Oh my god Yeah, we lost the fucking creek.
I can't believe it.
It's your fault chat.
You could you didn't you didn't do it for a Liberty Poor
chat.
I can't believe it chat.
How could you guys do that?
What happened to Liberty and democracy?
oh honestly it is cat's fault i don't even know what it
means what is this red line what is this red line i don't
know take us there wait we can pick where we go oh no wait
that's the visual bug on my side not you not you i can't
believe it how do i how do i how do i get like strong
weapons as well man i i you have to you have to spend money
to make to have the strong weapons now fuck that shit no you
don't you don't it's all in game you unlock it from the ship
i already spent 200 on this game it's not paid for you yeah
bro i'm gonna for you i'm gonna shell fucking dinner bro you
could have but he's paying for everyone you're paying for
whatever whatever you're buying everyone dinner right no
yeah even me right who do you guys think you are RPR?
Jokie?
Yeah.
I'm following.
Wait, why the fuck am I on a fucking...
Welcome to the robot land!
Bro, I just got boss?
Wait, robots?
Yeah, there's robots.
Oh, real gun!
Real gun.
You're not getting the real gun.
come on i'm gonna get my my machine i killed him i killed
him i killed him i should have gotten i should have gotten
the auto can oh my god are you crazy
wait this is this is one of the other movies right what
terminator yeah they have like these robot looking
terminator looking guys yeah all right let's go on my ping
guys we got It's Y2K.
Let's go.
I really want to shoot him.
Do it.
I mean, you can shoot him in the leg, I guess.
No.
Okay, sure.
I'll shoot him in the leg.
Do it.
He's literally right there.
Whoa.
Rocks his head.
I shot him with the leg.
Bro.
It just means my massive run.
Holy fuck.
bro that was like that was his chest i shot him in the leg
just with like a 50 caliber yeah those bullets definitely
went further beyond the leg right there uh-oh oh i'll kill
you all oh holy you guys are probably holy shit hey come
here uh press on this with me all right what is this it's uh
a bunker oh there's grenades
open up
wow there's some cool loot in here i'll take it thank you
thank you thank you all right see you guys later This is my
stream now.
What was she thinking?
Clutch your cake.
What were you thinking?
What do you think was going to happen?
Well, the problem was I wasn't really thinking.
I can't believe you've done this.
Solo season 2.
I'm solo.
Oh my god!
Wait, I realized I can play that now.
I can play on this.
Open up!
Oh shit, they can't fly!
I'm on solo.
Watch out, watch out, watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm watching.
Uh...
I mean, I did warn him.
Yeah, I don't think he watched out.
I mean, he said he was watching.
yeah we did watch yeah who's reinforcing like 10 of them
though at least you're watching you know yeah did he
actually kill 10 of them i don't think he did i didn't think
he actually did it all right we got it oh wait it's puzzle
time it's puzzle time do the puzzle do the thing go for it
go for it Zeller do the puzzle!
Use that massive brain of yours!
No, you have to spin the raider dish.
Wait, oh yeah.
Wait, we can spin it now?
No we can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, don't worry, I can spin it.
I know.
Over here, Doki, Doki.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You gotta spin it from over here.
Oh, shit, this big... This big robot!
I can kill those.
Wait, do you spin it from over here?
No, you're spinning here, where I am right now.
Oh, I can spin it!
Okay, how do you do this?
I'm on it.
Am I spinning it?
I'll let you know.
Okay.
Am I doing it?
Five, four, three, two, one.
Stop, stop, stop.
I can do a countdown for a reason!
We did it!
How do I get off?
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Yay!
I'm here.
Where are you going?
You gotta destroy these ships right here.
Okay.
All right.
Leave it to me.
Leave it to us.
It's a team game.
Hey, that looks like a grenade you just threw.
Wait, I got it.
I don't know what to do.
It's a nuclear bomb, but just you.
Whoa!
I threw a cluster bomb.
Run, run, run, run!
Run, run!
Oh, my God.
Are you crazy?
What do you mean?
What does that do?
Look, see?
Wow.
That was beautiful.
It's like fireworks.
I think it's cooler than RPRs.
What do you mean I dropped a nuke?
There was more explosions though.
Yeah, but mom was like big.
Yes, he killed everything.
Nice.
This is so easy.
Look at us.
We're working together.
Oh, behind me, behind me, behind me.
Oh, good luck.
Behind him, guys.
Guys, guys.
Guys.
Guys!
Guys, where are we?
we all split up wait how did i die help us yeah the baby
needs help the baby needs help let's kill them all now we're
back we're back let them know we're fine i got you i got you
see look at us working together whoa whoa this guy got flame
throws and i'm fucking blasting it's a hulk it's a hulk wait
wait this guy ain't taking damage this guy ain't taking
damage thank you i'm throwing a your nades are reliable what
do you mean i just really don't think the hook oh no oh no
i'm stimming oh my god it's at t t they're not real i got
you i got you i got you i got you guys i don't think he got
you i don't think he got you there were five of them behind
you bro What am I meant to do against five dudes like wave
my hand at them?
You had me, man.
Come on.
Yeah, you had him.
You could have done it.
No, I didn't have him.
Why did you say you had him?
Were you lying?
Maybe she can handle five guys, but I can't handle five
guys.
Okay.
There's a difference.
Oh, I don't care.
What's your limit for?
I would run.
I would run away.
Run away.
far why are we running wait we did we did it we did it wait
what was that man wait who are we missing we're missing
right now i don't know who did you guys kill earlier oh it's
mine hey guys
wait zeller if you come here look at this red no i step on
it and i die right i'm not that dumb that's loot that's loot
that's loser dude there's a tank i gotta i gotta do this for
us i gotta do this for us yeah that's i think i destroyed it
i threw nades at it i destroyed the tank oh my god what is
going on oh that's a tank that's a tank that's a tank i got
my Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got it.
No, the nades don't work.
I have a strike.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's going down.
I have a strike too.
Yeah, throw everything.
Throw the speed thing at the tank.
Let's do it.
We did it, sir!
The tank is low.
Sir!
We did it!
We went to mine!
The fucking mine!
I stepped out of mine!
No.
Guys, there's a tank.
I saw the tanks blow off I got so happy ran back and stepped
on a fucking mine yeah you can shoot the mine yes that's
what I'm doing we can just walk around it no more just don't
walk into the the red the red thing yeah you know normal
people will just not die to it yeah yeah what are you trying
to do what are you trying to do Zellie what were you trying
to do I built different nothing let's walk this way guys.
Okay.
Wait, Zeller has the Uber Eats.
Huh?
He has the Uber Eats.
Look at him.
Oh, hell yeah.
He has the Uber Eats.
I'll ring the door.
It'll be like, hey, yo, what's up, baby girl?
Let me get your Instagram.
Is this what you think?
No, this is what you think happens for Uber Eats?
Is this it?
No.
All the Uber Eats that I've ordered, they've been really
nice to me.
I've never had an asshole, except one who didn't come and
ate the food.
Uber eats people, like, go up to you and ask for your
Instagram?
No, they don't.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, my eyesight's blurry.
I can't see anything.
Yeah, return back to combat.
Traitor detected.
Who's the...
Did we all die?
Kill by Zellers.
By Zellers?
Zellers?
I said I died by explosion.
Traitor detected.
did because you look i'm killing everyone okay yes including
us apparently no they're flying i got you i got you i got
you i got you i got you i got you guys i got you bro he's
gonna dying bro i need a few damage i need a no you need to
know if you leave the combat zone uh the ship's above are
gonna start shooting like missiles at you so then i'm
guessing that you know zealous i'm guessing yes i was right
in front of them bro what the you literally was like why is
my vision blurry you literally said that to us what do you
mean no um no i'm what i'm aging you know
just follow me what do you mean how did i also asian we
didn't get bombed Ah, I don't know what you're talking
about.
I told you he said...
Oh my god.
Everyone except RPR is gonna be blurry.
But then RPR is like aging, aging.
So he'll be blurry too.
So in the end, we'll all be...
Uninstall the stream.
Run back!
There's a bomb!
Where do we go?
Oh shit!
There was a nuclear your bomb why didn't anyone talk about
it because i threw it away from you guys so you guys can die
oh that's so sweet oh oh terminator boys it's okay we're
fine we just we just better watch out behind there's so many
there's so many oh my god i'm dead guys i'm dead no i'm
running i only i'm
I missed.
Spawn us in, please.
We're doing so well.
Check it out.
Okay, yeah, yeah, I'm checking.
Oh, shit.
What was that?
My chest is bleeding.
It's okay.
I have a stim.
Okay, there's a guy with a big shield.
We need to kill him.
That is strong.
I got you.
Don't go anywhere near that.
I think I got him.
I got you.
I just shot him.
No, no, he's still alive.
He's still alive.
I see him.
Don't go near that.
No, go, go.
He's dead.
Selling, go.
You're a horrible person.
He is dead.
What do you mean?
I'll never die.
He was dead.
I was telling the truth.
Oh, shit, guys.
Okay, I'm going to get another machine gun.
I'm on fire.
What the fuck?
Oh shit, there's more.
I only have a pistol.
Zellie, get away from me.
I'm staying near you so you get the fucking damage.
My machine gun is literally coming down.
Yay.
You guys are doing great.
You're doing great, guys.
We're doing it.
We have like four left, so we're five.
Okay, I got another machine gun.
Objective.
We gotta go to objective.
I got an orbital strike.
Orbital strike.
Coming.
AT&T.
No, no, no, no.
Run back, run back, run back.
Return to tactical zone.
No, we have to return.
Oh no!
I'm getting hit.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
No bullets, I have no.
I need more bullets, I need more bullets, I need more
bullets.
Why are you shooting behind you?
I'm shooting behind you.
Wait, where's RPI?
We need to get to RPI.
I'm leaving you guys from.
You guys are still not.
Oh, machine gun.
You should probably 20 seconds guys, okay?
Wait, I'm running towards him.
I'm gonna get to you guys.
running from the supplies huh i'm running over here i don't
need that we don't need ammo we're we're so good we have
resupply we have resupply we don't need bullets okay i have
my machine my heavy machine gun just wants to give you guys
some ammo they were like oh i don't have any bullets i don't
have any bullets i wanted to give them bullets i have
machine gun now and i have grenades We got this, huh?
Just believe in us.
Here's the thing.
If we run away, we don't need ammo if we're not going to.
I'm not going to lie.
I gave up when you guys made the way.
I just started running away.
You're a horrible person.
How could you?
You should revoke your super citizen.
You're not a super citizen.
You don't help others.
Because instead of instead of.
Yeah.
Go.
Instead of what?
One second.
I was throwing a nuclear bomb.
Instead of fucking around with you guys, I'm liberating.
I'm liberating.
We're liberating too.
Yeah, you're liberating your brain cells.
What do you mean?
We're liberating.
We're doing our part.
I'm doing my part.
Yeah, I'm doing my part.
I'm doing my part too, being happy.
Like, we're here now.
See, RPO, we're here.
We're here.
Thanks for coming, guys.
That's a good lady.
That was not me, just so you know.
I got you.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, mine!
Landmine!
I got you.
No, I'm already dead.
The landmine got me already.
Oh, oh, shit.
I'm burning.
Someone get me too.
Okay, when you start burning, just heal.
And it will heal the blood.
Chainsaw, guys!
Why can't I stop dropping roll?
how it works in this world what so it was all alive i got
the machine it's it's it works on earth just not on where
the fuck where we are different atmosphere oh we're fine i'm
sorry grenade oh there's a big guy big guy big guy okay he's
fine i said i'm throwing a I said where are you throwing it?
Look at his loot.
I'm taking his loot.
He's right.
Oh shit.
I'm taking his loot too.
Looky railgun.
Oh fuck.
I didn't come.
Oh you thought you had it.
You thought you could.
You thought you could kill us.
Bro I look like everything I do for you.
And then you guys just robbed me.
Bro you ran into my nade.
What do you want me to do?
It's all putting into a trust fund when you die.
I need more bullets.
Yeah.
Oh man, only if only you went to the supply thing that I
gave you only you went there Look, I was saving mine.
Oh my one.
I stepped on it, but it didn't go off Look at us.
We're doing great.
I think we're doing pretty well.
Okay, okay.
Resupply resupply.
I got the resupply too No, we don't need them.
We don't need them.
Yes, we do.
I'm going to object them where's the objective what do we do
right in front of us okay what do we have to do we have to
destroy airbase control tower this is one of the harder ones
like this is gonna be fun what difficulty are we on uh hard
yeah oh this is hard it's so easy it's easy i know it was so
easy yeah well you know if you guys didn't team kill each
other it would be a lot easier where did we see you killed
yourself sounds like a problem i got burnt to death because
i'm too busy talking too dumb we can we can turn it down on
difficulty if you want yeah why did you heal rpr yeah what
happened to you we're cool we're we're cool with our
difficulty but up here yeah apparently he died like two
times in a row guys are not real you guys are not real don't
go near that oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm gonna Look, I'm
on a turret gun.
Holy shit.
Wow, get everybody that's behind us.
All right, we're here.
I'm here.
There's no one behind us.
I'm doing my part.
Yeah, you guys are fighting ghosts behind us while I'm
liberating this tower.
So good.
You don't know what's in front of us.
Oh, there's actual people in front of us.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, RPM, you died again.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
I got rocket launcher.
What just killed me?
How do we go over there, Jokie?
What the fuck?
Right here.
Oh, right here?
Okay, let's go.
Yeah.
Let me watch.
Let me watch the real content.
Oh my god.
He fell off.
Wait, how do I?
Okay, reload.
People from the right.
I got you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to figure out how to use this really good.
Easy money.
Cash money.
Oh, you shot me.
No, I shot the robot.
I shot the robot.
No, uh-uh.
You shot me.
I shot a robot.
He's dead.
I did my part.
How much?
44 seconds.
RPR, you need to stop dying.
We don't have enough grease on.
That's 15 times.
Look at us, RPRC.
We're doing it.
We are cooking.
We are doing it.
I'm grenade-ing.
That's not a good grenade.
You're going to kill us.
What do you mean?
You nearly killed us on solo out here.
I'm doing my best.
Greeter shot first and Greeter's still key.
I did it.
I mean, you didn't die.
You ran away.
You didn't die.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
I got shot by your fucking robot drone.
Hey, guys.
Five seconds, guys.
Oh, turret, turret, turret.
I got you.
Use the turret.
Where are they?
Oh, I got it.
I don't know how to use it correctly.
I'm getting it.
I don't know if there's any on this side.
There is.
I got one guy.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
They're fucking falling from the skies.
Where are they?
it's okay guys i'm killing everybody on my side i'm not
encountering anyone why is that it's okay i did it i killed
like 20.
oh man okay i'll do the mission guys don't worry you guys
keep killing i put the hard drive in what's this there's
explosive here i don't know where i am or who i am but i
know i'm gonna follow you i know you know what to do i'm
gonna follow you okay um we're just waiting it's all right
zeller over here oh no don't him do the thing i believe in
you okay i did it he did it yeah good job bro good job
zeller see leave it to me man leave it to me sellers we
don't need your rp i'm important to this team well okay
we're doing it okay oh yeah now uh now what behind now shoot
this guy i got you i got you i got you guys too reloading
reloading oh
Mission complete.
Let's go.
Now we just run.
Our prayers are ready, like, we're heading to the next area.
Yep, I'm just done with it.
We just run.
What do you mean we don't fly?
White hair is from stress.
He's already white hair.
Jump!
He's going to lose his hair after this.
Just fall damage.
I got the turret.
Oh!
An explosion killed me.
There's like...
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
We just killed us.
I don't know.
An explosion.
I don't know what happened.
We just killed us.
I don't know.
An explosion.
I think it was RPR's thingy.
No, it wasn't.
It was something from behind us.
Yeah, something exploded.
I got hit by it, too, but we're fine now.
It's okay.
Well, I'm not.
I'm dead.
We're fine.
We have reinforcements.
Reinforcement.
We got rocketed from behind.
He's going to rocketed us.
It's Zeller.
Oh, it's high.
I didn't do that.
He's so cheeky right now.
It was hot.
The moment he used that voice, that voice right there, you
know, you know.
He used the voice.
The world hates me.
Maybe I'll hate the world.
He lived long enough to become a villain.
Wait, you're looking for you now.
Wait, it's coming from the south.
a huge tower that's been shooting us that's what we're good
we're good we're good are we're good are we i'm gonna try to
orbital it i don't think you can orbital it i'm actually
maybe you could so scared don't be scared look at him go
look at him go oh my god oh my god they're everywhere
they're everywhere holy look at this gamer he's gaming you
have no stims he has no more Sims 20 seconds you don't think
I know that 20 seconds run to the fort run to the fort what
are you doing oh oh he's so fucked he is so fun he is so he
got this he got this bro he oh my god five seconds five
seconds bro it would be so funny what the oh holy shit go go
go go
This guy is an anime protagonist!
Oh, he killed him!
He's an anime protagonist!
Holy shit, he's cooking!
Those 10 hours!
He's a gamer!
Oh my god, he's like...
He's glitching!
Oh, he got shot in the crawl!
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
Why are you just holding that out?
Oh my god, and then...
I'm so sad if RPR just chill yeah before he has no meds you
know nothing.
I'm so sad if RPR dies while Zelen lived for as I ever lived
for so long.
I'm not gonna die okay I'm a professional.
That's a flag right there bro.
Mother RPR is the type of guy who's gonna tell the fucking
dude next is like after this war let's go back happily to
our family.
See, he died!
I told you!
Bro!
He died, I told you!
That worked so hard for them!
Holy shit!
What happened?
That worked so hard for you to live!
That phrase, after this war, let's go back to it.
Maybe jigs myself a little bit, but you fucking fucked me
until the end.
god you just made the strategy the strategy the extraction
you might as well i just go what you stepped on the smelly
bomb go go go go just run to the extraction just run that's
the plan 15 seconds and you get the best you mean who me
doesn't get team killed anybody let's hope do leave it to me
bro i got you man bro how do you guys know 15 seconds and
because it's on the top Oh, I'm back, bitches.
Leave it to me.
Well, no, if it's Zeller, I don't really want to be the one
that's, like, I'm one day away from retirement.
What the fuck is this bot drop?
Why are they calling me a bot, bro?
Zeller, like, do not land on Han.
He worked so hard to get here.
I'm a lie.
Are you healed up?
Yeah, yeah, he's healed up.
He's good now.
Just one minute and 36 seconds.
Just keep going to extraction point.
You're so close.
Actually, don't even know.
We still have to wait two minutes.
It's not very good.
You know what?
It's so winnable.
Maybe I don't need you anymore.
No!
Get some rid of it.
Put him down old yellow style.
Just like as the ship is dropping down, you're like, you
know what?
This was a solo mission.
I'm just gonna spectate the zealers because I know he's
gonna provide content fuck you mean I ain't got no condo how
do I slide how do I slide it's all you mean like oh shit
people in front of us guys careful careful careful I want to
there's an orbital strike there's an orbital strike zeller
be careful it's not hitting the single person that I'm
trying to shoot wait did he die
Don't die, don't die, don't die.
Just run, just run, just run.
Just run, just run.
Just run.
Oh, you die, you little bitch.
Die, you little bitch.
Why is there a fucking tank over here?
Just run.
Go back.
I think you were better off solo.
Don't go back, Sully.
Don't go back.
This, watch me.
10 seconds.
Oh, I'm sorry.
back if you respond me i'm gonna be back and we're like what
do i do to respond we're like the dream team i know do it
now do it now do it now okay uh uh respond how the fuck got
yourself lift up okay so you know how you were summoning
strategies it's a i can't kill you no he's dead he you die
you're dead you're dead we're back No!
Oh, no!
Doki, you're a final hug.
Oh, you're alone.
You're alone, buddy.
I don't want to be alone.
Doki, one, Kenobi.
You're our only hug.
Oh, we're so...
We were doing so good.
You were not doing good at all.
You killed them.
So scary.
Minutes 25.
Okay, one minute, one minute, one minute.
Okay, okay.
Doki, one Kenobi is crazy.
It's okay.
There's no robots coming in.
We're fine.
We can we can chill There's no one coming in Nice There's
nobody here.
That's just a robot right there.
No, it's not.
No, where?
On the just just crouch in the corner.
Yeah, you're right.
You know, yeah, right in the corner Show your superiority.
There's nobody here.
They got they all shot Zeller before they shot his song.
Oh, yeah I took all the hate.
I took all the aggro for you.
He took all the aggro.
Apparently you don't know how to use the map.
You have to press tab for map.
No, I do.
I just follow you guys because it's easy.
Okay, we're the map.
Okay, I got it.
Yeah, you guys are the map.
I don't need to look at the map.
If you guys can look at the map for me.
Yeah, that's what teammates are for.
Yeah, look at that.
I'm doing the best.
You know what?
I think I've done the best out of all of you guys.
I have nobody on me.
It's the safest we've ever been.
You've got a point.
Yeah, nobody's here.
Oh.
No.
Shit.
It's okay.
Two seconds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Go RPR, go.
I'm ready.
It's like Pokemon.
I'm going to lend them to her.
Okay, okay.
Two more minutes until...
Two more minutes.
minute until Han Solo, the strongest member comes back.
The strongest man and the team comes back.
We have Doki Wan Kenobi.
We have R.P.R.T.
R2-D2.
R.R.
R .2-D2.
R .T.
R.P.
R .P.
R .2-D2.
How the fuck am I R2-D2?
There's drop shippers, by the way.
Doki Wan Kenobi.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming over.
Oh!
that's a lot of robots over there where do i go r2d2 where
do i go okay do not call me r2d2
zelar binks who is that i don't even know i've never watched
the star wars oh zelar binks zelar binks is like the
strongest character in star wars he's like a sift lord yeah
he's a sift lord
Run!
Oh, it's okay!
Oh, it's all coming from behind as well.
Oh, it's okay.
I got one.
You got one only?
I got one, guys.
I did my part.
Zellar, Lara Banks.
Okay, I got two.
I'm burning, I'm burning, I'm burning.
How are you burning?
You have 30 more seconds!
30 more seconds!
actual carry okay i'm you know what i'm gonna leave you then
you can wait for him i'm gonna go fucking do the mission
wait what what do you mean you're waiting for a carry right
you don't need me i'm i don't care i don't care you so i'm
just gonna go do the mission you need to get carried you
should stay near us so hot solo no no no i'm fine i'm fine
you guys got that but are you no no you're reinforcing i got
you need to help i got you han solo thank you thank you
let's go back to r2d2 no you guys don't need me right so we
so everybody's good right yeah yeah everybody's good right i
will kill you dead cat talk
come heading over i'm heading over i'm trying to run i have
no more stamina right here i'm almost there whoa you are too
easy what's the fun Doki D2.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, I'm burning, but I'm fine.
I'm heading over to R2 D2.
We have to go southwest, southwest.
40 seconds, and then we'll have another respawn for one of
us.
And I'll be back.
And I will carry you guys once again.
Hey, R2 D2, we're here.
Yeah, we have problems.
Wait, I like how you acknowledge that you're R2 D2.
you.
Okay.
You responded to that.
I'll never talk in again.
Can the railgun not break these?
Wow!
Are you kidding?
That tower, Tower, careful that tower!
There's a tower!
This tower?
On the entrance point!
Oh shit, oh shit, I'm running away.
I'm running away.
You have an orbital that you can shoot that thing away.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, I do.
Give me a sec.
I need to remember how to do this.
Uh...
I'm gonna...
Oh, no!
Oh, I missed people behind!
I'm going across the map.
Holy crap.
What happened?
Oh, God.
I got shot by the laser.
He got tower.
No!
I got tower too!
Okay.
RPR prove to us that you're the carry.
Come on.
Show us what you got.
RPR.
I don't really have much ammo.
Reinforce me.
Yeah, well, you got me if you reinforce me, yo.
Can you land on the...
You want me to go land on the guy?
Land on the tower.
Let's see if my aim is good enough to land on the tower,
bro.
Don't land on me, please.
Where the fuck?
I can't, bro.
This is impossible.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He's got no aim and no bitches.
Dude, I was so far away from the...
All right.
What about a grenade for the tower?
No, no.
That will not work.
Okay.
It doesn't work.
Yeah, I tried.
Oh, he's shit.
He's shit.
Did he just sound shit?
Oh, I'm burning, I'm burning, I'm burning.
Heal yourself, heal, heal, heal.
Heal, heal, heal.
You're doing so well.
You're doing so well, Seller.
This is my last reload.
Do you not have resupply?
No, it's over there.
Look at it.
I'll get the resupply.
Come to me, come to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can't get some cooldown.
Seller, Seller, Seller.
There's a tank behind our PR.
Do not go behind him.
Where's the extraction point?
Why aren't you guys going to extraction?
We don't need these extra.
Oh!
Dead, rough.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what do I do?
What do I do?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, Seller, Seller.
Run and heal.
Just like how haunted.
Just run and heal.
Just run and heal!
Don't run towards them!
Oh, he's going to die to the tower.
He's going to die to the tower.
No, he's not.
Just keep running.
Run away from them.
Get away.
Run, even if we miss this, uh, Even if we miss this EVAC,
there's going to be an emergency one.
So, just stay alive.
Just stay.
Well, we didn't finish the mission.
We did.
We just need extraction.
20 seconds.
20 seconds and you get Han Solo back.
We're going to run out of bounds.
No, I hate this game.
Why am I out of bounds?
That's not out of bounds.
So, I was like, it's...
10 seconds.
Bring me in, coach.
Don't worry, the carry is coming back soon!
Yeah, get the carry, get the carry in!
Bring me in!
I wanna try, give me a second.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta go this way.
Give me a second, okay?
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck!
Oh fuck!
Leave me alone!
I did nothing!
I'm coming back in, I'm coming back in!
He's coming!
We got the English!
We got the emergency.
It's me.
Oh, no, it's hot.
It's hot.
Okay, thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, wait a minute.
One minute, 50 seconds.
You got this hot.
You can do this again.
Where's the extract?
I tried my best.
Bro, that was out of zone.
I got cornered.
You did that to yourself, bro.
You did that to yourself, though.
No, I didn't.
They didn't tell me which way you went.
to go man we can't see the map when we're dead i don't care
i like how like han comes down and everybody there's no
enemies after that baby girl he's just chilling one minute
left oh wait wait a minute you have to head there for in one
minute wait isn't this point wait you want you will not be
able to you will not be able to raise anyone because the
reinforce and the ship believes the stratosphere the same
time so oh no it's literally same time oh wait i don't even
it's a four minute defense it's a four minute defense i
think we already salutations salutations i think we already
force be with you four minutes of quality content right okay
i believe rpr for not to take us to extraction He wouldn't
do it a bonus mission.
It's not it's my fault that you guys kept team killing each
other for 15 deaths.
We did we're not team killing each other.
It was that we were not team killing each other.
No, imagine that.
The difficulty was just too hard for us.
Okay.
The copium in the gaslighting.
Oh no.
The destroyer has left.
That's good.
good we are the destroyer we are the destroyer oh what i
thought they're the bad guys we were the
reinforcements well look they can't find him oh i wonder if
they know where he is they have wall hacks this isn't fair
it's okay ha just keep running just keep running for two two
minutes and 30 I got captain see this is what happened to me
they cornered me like this man wait where are you shooting
wait oh no you don't have enough stems for this but how many
stems do you have left ah two oh why did they only give us
four stems these guys are stingy man they should give us
like 99 stems because can you not see what we're armor we're
wearing like how the fuck do you fit more than four in that
i don't know make the steams more like fucking compact i
guess
i believe i believe in him rpr why don't you believe in him
do i have to say that i believe in him like what oh my god
now he does and now he's dead Believe in him.
Why did you believe in him?
He jinxed him What the fuck Where did your head go?
Where did it go?
Got no head.
Mission completed.
Oh my god Han Solo couldn't clutch anymore You couldn't
clutch it I believe you know what I believe I believe R2D
too yes yeah our super citizen wasn't so super yeah he
looked like a free-to-play player
Monserra died and started screaming I'm getting tea bags
Don't let shit sell it!
Well done!
What the fuck?
Bro!
Look at me.
Only 50 friendly car damage.
Bro!
Six and two case crazy.
How did you get to 6,000?
Not at all, man.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
But look, shots fired 1,456.
Yeah, and 1,400 of them were at us.
Yeah.
No.
Cancer.
Come on, guys.
What do you mean?
Come on.
Sats don't lie.
Sats don't fucking lie.
Come on, guys.
12 times.
12 of our respawns were on him.
Hey, you're fault for killing me if you guys let me live,
you know?
What do you mean, Arfa?
Who killed?
Who?
Who killed you?
Who was it?
You guys all killed me.
What do you mean?
Who hurt you?
All right, let's see.
Oh, I'm going to have a machine gun sentry.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to buy a galling sentry.
I got a vitality enhancement so we can live.
Nice.
Oh, a bite.
mean like you don't die as fast oh so it like applies to all
of us yeah so i can shoot zeller three times instead nice oh
my god zeller can break 10k wait i i want i want the rifle i
want the rifle i want the rifle are rifles strong or are
they weak um what rifle are you using shotguns the best oh
is it somebody said rpr but viagra vitality vitality what
someone has the hell pod one right hell diamond the helipods
fuck fuck yeah i have the help on where are we going here
where do we go uh by this one because you have to do this
too so we can do the rocket so let's do this one
I got sentry I'm gonna go with out of cannon this time I
think out of cannon stronger against automatons I'm gonna
bring a shield generator I'm gonna bring my only two that I
have What did you have He has a shield He has orbital and
the machine gun You know you can buy stuff I'm pretty sure
you have enough money to buy things now I didn't know you
could buy stuff help with optimization in wow i did okay
good that one allows you to respond with full armor and shit
i got two mortars one ems one actual mortars so i have i
have machine gun i've kept galling and i have a galling gun
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was saying you want to go to a
white i don't have to shoot my gun i can have let the These
guys do it for me.
Alright, machine gun.
Whoa, whoa, that's so far away.
Holy shit.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm grabbing my machine gun.
RPO, you want to see something funny?
Yeah.
What's the funny thing?
I'm not going to do it.
Coward.
I whimped out.
Coward, do it.
Not me.
I got a machine gun too guys.
You're in between.
Oh shit, that's a little patrol.
Yeah.
I shot the guy that called for reinforcements, so it should
be.
Never mind.
Nice.
Not a one-fold for it.
The bot drop detected.
You did it, RPR.
There was two of them.
Okay, at least I shot one of them.
Did you shoot one?
No, he didn't.
Yes, but you're a super citizen.
You should have been able to shoot both.
I'm not super citizen right now.
that tags a lie so you gave up your citizenship yeah you
gave me your traitor oh my god you're not here for democracy
and Liberty oh oh just gonna not talk to you guys and focus
on shooting guys shoot the back shoot the back wait wait
what do you mean I shot the back I shoot the back I shot the
back oh this guy good job good job good job all right I'm
reloading are you okay hon i'm good i'm good all right we're
fine i knew he was fine i had the power of friendship yay
see rpr why can't you have the power of friendship just wait
wait this side this side this uh 350 350 350.
don't worry i'm i'm shooting my gun hey we're good we're
good we're good everything's good do some bullshit by us i
gotta reload where do we go here on me but yeah see this is
why i don't need to look at my map i can just follow you
whoa she she's screaming something she said for super
yeah i need more bullet i need more bullet i need more
bullet oh here it's right here right where Right here, right
here.
Right here, right now.
Oh,
is that bullet?
Bro, he slapped me.
No, I didn't.
I missed.
Bro, he hit me.
What?
Oh, my God, I'm going to cancel you right now.
Yeah.
Make him X longer.
Oh, I just got one shot by that.
Oh, we need a save.
Someone res.
Well, I'm taking him on a walk.
I'm taking this guy on a walk.
I got you.
I'm taking Mr. Flamethrower on a walk.
Oh, it's a Hulk.
Oh, no.
He's back.
I'm shooting.
I killed him.
I took him out of one.
He's gonna look at me.
Dude, I clutched up there, baby.
See?
I told you.
Leave it.
Yeah, I just watched Ducky literally sit in front of me and
tank the flamethrower.
That was great.
Bro, I did that for you.
For me?
I was not in danger.
I did that for you.
I aggroed it.
Activated transformer.
Where do we go?
Gotta activate this transformer.
Don't worry guys.
There's a reloaded machine got here there's a reload i'll
just do everything guys yay he did it he did everything
let's go all right next up let's go all right sweet nice
great teamwork baby let's go are we a good team rpr yeah
yeah great team dude i was that flame throwing guys in the
back holy shit man we're so good at this game even to me
hell yeah can i not out of can on this thing could i got you
can i get up here oh wait i'm gonna orbital strike watch out
watch out watch out watch out watch out oh yeah i should
have my strength this might be my favorite group of idiots
look to the left holy 300 wait 300 300 wait there's a
fucking ah fucking horde of them coming over here wait where
that was huge oh that was a huge neg yeah oh never mind it
Okay.
I practice so much by blowing you guys up.
I'm so used to these grenades now.
Leave it to me, yo.
You just detected a huge horde to us.
What did you practice by blowing?
Do you also swallow?
Whoa.
No, I don't swallow.
No, I will never.
I will never.
Holy shit, guys.
Wait, wait.
There's a big guy.
Ah, I'm slipping.
Yeah, we saw him.
I might die.
Zeller, we left you.
You guys are horrible.
You killed me.
you yeah who killed you killed me what do you mean after
after all i've done after all i did to you my god oh you
suck so much dick
spawn us in you guys killed me i'm back
bro leave it to me yo oh man i spotted for the playthrough
I'm fucking in the back.
Nice.
It's okay.
I saw we did it.
We did it.
Hear that?
He fucked him in the back.
Oh, yeah.
Man, we did it, guys.
We defeated the Hulk.
Not even close.
Not even close, baby.
Next up is this big red area right here.
Let's go.
Aye, aye, aye.
Nice.
All right.
Where is that?
Follow me.
All right.
Guys, I need a machine gun ammo if anybody has extra ammo.
Let me get you with a resupply.
Nice.
Oh my god, our peer discovered heavy outpost and he also
died.
Let's play resupply chicken.
Resupply chicken, let's go.
No, you're bigger chicken than I am.
That's three hooks.
I nuclear bombed it.
That's four hooks.
Oh wait, there's even more.
There's even more.
Fuck.
We're coming over.
I exploded a bunch of them, but they didn't die to a nuclear
fucking bomb.
Hello?
It's okay.
I'm gonna flank around I'm gonna flank around guys.
Oh, no, they're all focused on me.
Oh, no, they're all focused on me Oh, god.
Oh, god.
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm machine gunning.
I got a nuclear bomb as well Nuclear orbit.
I dropped it.
How did you have a bomb?
An orbit an orbit.
I threw it.
I don't know if I could do anything though.
Oh my god.
I got rocketed in my ass.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
I have I have a eagle cluster.
I'm throwing it.
I think I did something.
I killed the cannon.
I killed the cannon here.
Eagle cluster on my ass.
What do you mean it's helpful?
It's coming down.
What are you eagle cluster?
Oh!
You killed me!
Tom and Ziller got eagle clustered by Doki.
Oh, some sick moves.
I said I called out my eagle cluster.
I killed the flamethrower guy though.
I killed one.
point you might as well just be like i'm gonna kill you i'm
gonna kill you i'm gonna kill you yeah but you guys still
didn't know it was happening oh no i landed right in front
of mr flame throw it's okay i'm fucking killing him pretty
good he's dead guys there's two more though okay guys i'm
gonna put an orb on our strike this time okay there's two
more of these motherfuckers wait how do i wait i have the
gallon gun use it will you i use it We both said the same
thing.
It's coming down!
I'm helping!
Yeah, that was very helpful, Doki.
That was sick, yeah.
Just give the enemy the fucking weapon as well next time.
What?
It's my... No, it's my Gatling gun!
Turret!
I got you!
Whoa!
It's a turret!
It's helping!
Oh my god, I'm so helpful.
Yes, it is!
Look at him!
He's shooting the thing!
I'm looking at him shoot!
Look at him go.
Oh my god.
There's so many things.
I got one more Hulk.
It's okay.
Okay.
We're five.
Not today, bitches.
Nice.
Let's go.
We did it.
We're doing it.
We killed the small trash now and then all the resupply
because holy fuck.
I got nothing.
Oh.
We're doing our part.
Why?
I'm going to do an orbital over there.
There's another one.
There's an orbital.
Wait, I have enough for Eagle Strike.
Yeah, a lot of Eagle Strikes.
I'm throwing it.
Eagle Strike.
I'm running too.
I'm going to run.
I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill you right now.
Great comms.
I get it.
I'm so proud of you.
One more.
You still didn't die.
There's another orbital strike.
That one's not mine.
do more i'll shoot the back i'll shoot the back nice okay
i'll sit here and look pretty then i am what the is this
he's throwing me around i'm gonna grenade oh no he's looking
at me now he's looking at me now nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice nice nice nice nice look at us guys we're getting
we're getting naded from the west oh okay oh sorry sorry
okay we're too next time Where do we go?
RPR.
Wait, I'm dealing with the rest of this trash here.
We can help.
Yeah, shoot his right leg without a cannon.
That's okay, I threw a grenade.
Right leg without a cannon, huh?
Nice.
We did it!
There's still one more.
Yeah, he's like all the way up in front of us.
Got you, I'm flanking him.
Don't worry, I'm flanking him with you.
He won't expect two flankers.
I'm in range of the enemy.
Enemy artillery.
There is a guy right in front of you.
I got it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right.
Let's go.
So, so, so.
Yeah, we did it.
More ammo.
More ammo on me.
I'm over here.
Oh, nice.
I have no more ammo.
All right, guys.
Next up, we got to go here.
Where's here?
Oh, just follow me, man.
You got to babysit us.
West.
Yeah, just fucking follow me.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're here, we're here, we're here.
Throwing resupply and resupply.
Oh my god, that's for us.
For us?
Did you fucking shoot me?
No, we're shooting people behind us.
No, why were we ever shooting you?
Yeah, why were we team?
We're a team.
Yeah, of course you guys don't do that ever.
Yeah, if we don't, wow.
It's crazy.
You can trust the mom.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
The fucking bombs, they're flying over here.
Where?
It's more to strike.
Coming in.
Careful.
Oh, this resupply is bugged.
No, I got one.
I cannot get one.
Whoa.
There's people behind us.
I'm needing.
They're dead.
What is this?
What is this resupply?
I don't know.
You're the one that put it down there.
What the fuck?
The bombs are nutty.
Yo, this is on you.
This is actually on you.
Oh, that's fine.
All right.
There you go.
We do that We got to go.
We got to go.
Okay.
Go go go.
Are we gonna erase this guy?
I got you.
I got you got you.
Oh, wait.
He said when did he die?
The ball?
You know shit happens.
When did he die?
Bum, but I'm but I'm Okay.
I'm back.
Nice.
We, can we, oh, we need to have, we have to reset one more
objective.
I live another day.
Wait, how did you guys?
Oh no.
I got, I got, I got two show boys on me.
Two show boys.
Wait, how are we gonna get to the- Just raise me, just raise
me.
I raise you, I raise you.
Where's the shield, boys?
Right next to the spawner.
Gotcha.
We got you.
I just died.
As soon as you landed?
Inside my health pod.
I'm so proud of you sacrificing one for the team.
Thank you for your sacrifice, RPI.
You really have it.
Yay, freedom!
Freedom!
out of you.
He did it.
A real citizen.
Wow.
Shannon Tori.
We did it.
How does that even...
Oh, there's more.
Oh, he's shooting at us right now.
Careful, careful, careful.
Careful.
This is wild.
That's an artillery shooting at us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to get away from that right now.
I'm back.
Where's the artillery?
I guess you guys don't.
I'm gonna do you guys.
It's right here.
We should get we should extract guys.
We should extract I mean we could we could get rid of all of
this red stuff on the map Truly nine lives.
Yo, fuck you're right.
We have nine lives.
We can do this.
I believe you okay Look on the right look on the right go
kill that fucking spawner and right okay.
Okay, okay us three on the right.
Okay.
Where are you gonna go rpr?
Where are you gonna go?
I'm gonna loot this cannon with artillery shots Oh god.
Oh god.
Wait wait.
I have enough for eagle cluster We're in the Dota!
Eagle cluster, Eagle cluster!
Eagle cluster!
Oh no!
Run, run, run, run, run!
No, no, no, no!
Run, run, run!
Oh stinky!
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
I won't throw you into the Eagle cluster.
I mean, you could.
I wouldn't really.
Nice, good, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
It's okay.
It's just God.
So we cleared this area, did we?
Yeah, we did.
Yep.
I eagerly needed.
Nice, Eagle cluster.
Don't take that.
You just you ain't get right in front of me.
You evil, evil man.
I'm totally not interested in what's going on over there.
How do I how do I drop this?
How do I drop this, bro?
I forget.
Oh, there we go.
Here you go.
You got it.
I picked up Doki's wish.
Ah.
I'm back bitches I'm back How are you guys dying all the
time What happened?
You left us alone You left us alone Now look what's going my
god bring me back i mean you can handle you guys right we
can't take care of ourselves hon yeah yeah yeah you got that
right yeah we're good we're good hon we're at mine
jesus christ come back come back you serial killer bring me
back welcome back Oh Bring me back I'm back.
I'm back guys.
There's a scary dude near RPR.
It's like nothing happened Oh a Hulk All right, where do we
go?
Yo, yo, how do I use it?
Keep running in circles.
It's okay.
Nade I got it.
We did it.
Where's the distracting?
We gotta go get these sentry guns.
Fuck these things are oh my god.
Oh Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, we gotta get that turret.
We gotta get that turret, guys.
I'm trying.
I can go for a solo mission.
I got you.
Point me towards the...
Point me towards it.
Oh my god!
It turns over there!
It's...
Oh!
Okay.
I think I got the turret with this one.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm gone with you, RBR.
We got this.
I'm so scared.
I'm just gonna hide behind you get it.
You get the turret?
I can't see.
One turret's dead.
You get it?
Okay.
I can ego strike.
If all I else bells, I have ego.
Oh shit, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm
stuck.
Eagle cluster!
Nice.
Oh, there's an AT&T behind us.
I'm gonna orbital strike this.
Oh, boy.
Orbital strike.
Oh no.
What the hell was that?
Yeah, yeah, I'll strike my ass.
I'm dead.
Wow.
My strike hasn't even hit yet.
What if it wouldn't kill me then?
I don't know that it hasn't even hit yet.
I wasn't mine.
OK.
Where's the other turret?
Oh, I don't know.
There is no.
I don't think there is a turret.
It's an artillery thing.
How do we get rid of the artillery?
We got to find it and then explode it.
Or we could just leave.
Wait.
Well, I mean, yeah, but you know.
What's the fun, Dodd?
We have three more rebats.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
I am right here.
Wait, I can like, can I...
If I land on the robot, does it do damage?
Yeah, it kills it, it kills it.
I'll mark it.
Oh, it's dead.
It's dead.
You're welcome, guys.
Hey, welcome on in.
For damage by me, chaps.
Guys, we have two reinforcements left, guys.
Okay, let's go to the objective.
Let's go here.
All right, all right, I'm following you, hon.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I see the artillery.
I'll get rid of your turret.
Yay, I believe in your RPR.
You can do this for us.
Oh, it's not that way?
Okay, I gotta go around.
Okay, I believe less than you now.
You still kind of believe in me, right?
Oh Wait, I thought you were I thought you were getting rid
of the artillery.
What's this?
What is this?
So many guys it sounds like Cossacks in this game.
Holy shit
Okay, okay, um Oh Oh, the fuck are you?
So are you are you reinforcing me are you reinforcing him?
Let me let me Let me do it, let me do it.
Yeah, there's a lot of people out of me right now.
Okay, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I have a bunch of them on me.
This is okay, I'm heading over, I'm heading over to you.
Nice, nice, nice, cover up and appreciate it if you need to.
It's okay, it's okay.
I made them run around in a circle, so we're fine.
I got the nade, I got the nade, nade down.
All right.
I got one only.
Okay, I'm heading up back.
Watch out, I'm needing, I'm needing, I'm needing, careful,
careful, careful, okay, okay.
Okay, we run back, we run back.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
We're doing it.
We don't need a super siege.
There's an auto cannon in battle.
Oh my god.
Almost fucking.
Not do damage to it.
Let's go northeast.
Northeast.
Oh, northeast is this way.
Okay.
Oh no.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
We have last reinforce.
Hunt, did you got that hunt?
Yep.
I'm gonna throw a grenade behind us.
Up here is just chilling, bro.
Bro, we have all of the bombs.
us go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
run seller run yes i'm running i'm running i'm running just
run oh my god anybody that we don't need to yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah just keep running oh my god we did it we got the
artillery good job you guys we did it hey we did it okay
We're team!
We aggroed the rest of the pod!
We were the distractions.
Yeah, we're the distractions.
Yep, exactly.
Yeah, we did our job.
Yeah, yeah, no, you guys did great.
Good job, Wes.
Yeah!
Run this way so you don't aggro those big guys.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
Oh!
It's okay.
They didn't see us.
They don't see us.
We don't have any of the aggro.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
We going in.
What are we going sneaky bekey like?
where's oh my gosh the extraction so far it's okay it's okay
we're gathering more reinforcements anyway oh no they saw us
oh what on on what did you do what did you do we did it we
did it yeah you guys did this as well it's crazy you guys
keep doing it i'm actually dead to fire i'm not actually i'm
alive somehow i live wait you don't have any stims i'm
calling a resupply just to get stims because i don't all
right we're all good we resupply by dying yeah exactly good
job guys you can count on us we never need a resupply we
just keep coming back exactly legends never die here we go
where do we go is it Oh, is this the...
Is this the...
Is this extra?
Oh, do you just take us to extra instead of extraction?
No, this is what we have to do.
We have to launch the missile.
Can you guys unlock that down there?
Okay, yeah, I can do that.
Ow, I took fall damage.
Oh, shit, save my fucking kneecaps.
Alright, I got this.
I'll go from left, you go from right.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
We got two.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm not gonna go.
I stand in the middle of it.
You're probably gonna die.
Wait, we have one reinforcement.
Don't be a coward.
Watch this.
Wait, there's...
Okay, actually, no.
Wait, there's actually fucking guys next to us.
Wait a minute.
Oh, they're jumping on me.
Oh, they can fly.
Oh, what an explosion killed me.
You guys have one rose.
You guys are fine.
Oh, no.
But what about me?
I wanted that rose.
What was that explosion from?
Oh.
Oh god.
Okay, that's why I come up here.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Actually, don't come up here.
Don't come up here.
Okay, I'm not coming over.
I'm not coming over.
Nice landing.
You guys are doing great.
You guys are going to be, you guys are going to live.
You guys are going to survive.
We're going to live.
I believe in us.
Oh, no, there's a shield.
Yeah.
I'm going to throw my nades.
I don't have nades.
I'm shooting him in the cross.
I'm jumping my nade.
I dropped the nade.
Ego.
That's so bad.
Run, run, run at Ego.
I'm trying my best to run.
Just run.
Ego's coming in.
I lost so many frames there.
It's okay.
We did it.
The Ego worked.
Nice, that actually worked.
Yeah, that actually worked.
Wah.
Wait, wait.
Whoa, shit!
Oh, that was dangerous.
Oh, boy, I dodged it last minute.
Oh, my God.
Han, what's that?
You guys are going through war, and I'm over here just...
That was not me.
Just chilling.
Han.
It was a red one.
It was the enemies.
It wasn't me.
I can't stand for this abuse.
Wow!
Han, Han, remember everything we've done.
Remember all the things we've done.
We were all the bots we killed together.
I just met you.
Yeah, today's the first time we met, you know?
I don't know what you...
The last two hours, remember?
Today's the first day we met.
I don't know what you thought of that.
Yeah, and now we're as close as ever.
War makes strong bond.
Brothers in arms.
We're brothers in arms.
Remember that.
I will say, like, you guys are alive for longer than I told
you would be.
Did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
I think.
oh five oh we also have a resupply we should call real
supply one yeah resupply is coming in so rpr doesn't get it
okay god okay i mean i don't need it but that's kind of mean
after everything i've done for you guys she's like yeah
let's just him hey we got the You cleared the launch codes.
We did that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I did all the fucking side objectives.
Yeah, but that's where there's side objectives.
Get you in.
You should take that.
You're not going to be staying there when the money comes
in.
Let's go.
Dang, I should really watch the Starship Troop of Movies
again.
This should- Is that how you want to watch it with me?
I've never watched it either.
I've watched that first one.
Oh my goodness.
I should watch it together after dinner.
After dinner.
We're going to be like, oh, oh.
there's people shooting at us oh nice good job thank you
thank you thank you we're all here the game's all here
there's like a guy yeah look at your life guys it's fun over
there on the left side oh yeah look at that i'm gonna reload
my gun real fast what was that was that another artillery no
no oh okay okay he's dead now okay he's got murdered whoa i
swear something is shooting us wait wait wait that's
literally a cannon right in front of me there's literally a
cannon right in front of me does anybody have an orbital
strike on that thing i do i got it i got it i got it i got
it i think i think i think i got it i got it leave it to me
you already put it down yeah put it down put it down put it
down oh shit bitch i'm right near the cannon i'm gonna die
it's okay it's okay you'll be fine just don't look at it if
you don't look
uh i don't know oh oh yeah just a small army got spawned on
me it's all good that's it it's not on us so it's okay um i
don't think i'm gonna go destroy it yeah it's just straight
guys i don't think the the tower got destroyed yet i threw
another one over there be careful all right it's fine we're
not looking at it wait so where is the where is the
extraction uh pinged it right here all right we'll follow
you hard see that little uh orange whoa no i do not Little
orange arrow on the top of your screen.
What's this?
Hey guys, Nina reinforced.
Oh, metal.
I stole the metal.
Oh, and it's okay.
It's all of us.
We all get it.
No, you just look like a bad person.
Oh, we have.
There's ammo.
There's grenades.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
RPI user or user reinforcements?
Yeah, I used one out of the way that you guys used.
what do you mean what do you mean what is that we used well
i can't believe you wasted our one guys i'm stuck guys i'm
stuck don't go that way don't go that way don't go that way
i need help i need help i need so much help oh he needs help
but he's dead anyways it's okay we have a minute so many
samples there no that's all right don't worry guys let's
show let's show him that we we don't need his guidance we're
strong enough we're strong babies together strong we don't
want to play with them anymore rip the samples man i work so
hard for them bitches we're coming over hon we're coming
over let's go channel and bounce oh my god we're gonna get
extractioned that's right we're gonna get extractioned i'm
stuck i'm stuck guys
this is going great don't go that way okay easy easy easy
see we made it 30 seconds on these points okay okay i have i
also have a gun uh galling gun here you go i know this will
be helpful right here oh i can interact with these carts
yeah it gives you information do not operate oh i thought i
could i thought i could ride on it why oh wait but we don't
have the we don't have like extra lives for it we don't have
extra lives for it okay okay no you don't want to do that i
got you i got you hit after all the money i just made you
you don't want to respawn me it's crazy
guy vi what the fuck that's fucked up that's fucked up can i
shoot through this or do i yes you can shoot through it you
can shoot okay that's why it was like a give me shield it
only lasts for a certain amount of time though oh oh oh oh
she died again i have samples yeah i'm trying to pick them
out but it's not really going well for me
eyes on me you love oh my gosh oh fuck oh fuck me guys it's
okay I'm watching for my dead body guys in one minute I come
back don't worry I'm gonna throw the orbital strike in the
center guys okay if I wasn't dead I could have on the left
on the left behind us too far from extract wait the shadows
are boarding in seconds you gotta be closer my body my body
getting close getting close it's already dead there's so
many of these chainsaw bros got them got one guys don't
worry i'm gonna land on a robot i'm gonna land on one of
them kobe last reload not good oh that's not me sorry that's
that's not that i thought i was coming in I was going to
say, you're going to land on one of him.
You land on someone, man.
That's crazy.
I'm out of ammo.
I'm out of ammo too.
Guys, it's okay.
I have an eagle cluster.
No.
Oh, no.
Get me in there.
She has eagle cluster.
I have eagle cluster.
Don't worry.
Guys.
I'm trying to.
guys i'm i'm i'm i'm surviving i spawned there i spawned
there nice nice nice who died i'm i got like three chainsaw
guys on me bro they want my ass so bad i got you i got you i
got no ass man what am i doing mr chainsaw okay nice nice
nice nice i have eagle cluster i'm playing with a Fucking
handgun right now.
Focus the back, focus the back.
I got the orbital.
Hold on.
Focus the back for her.
Okay.
There's a gun.
There's a gun here.
Oh, I'm getting fucked on.
Wait, wait.
I'm picking up the guns.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm gonna put up my gumbling gun.
Oh, fuck.
Run, Zelle.
Zelle's coming in.
Split up.
I'm splitting up.
Oh, I can't split up because they shut out inbound.
Oh.
Okay, wait, there's this the flamethrower guys on me
Shuttle's approaching.
I'm sorry.
Thanks for you I'm going to the shuttle.
I'm dodging all his moves right now.
Faker Guys get in get in get in No, no, no wait 45 seconds.
It's 40 seconds.
She got me.
Oh Sorry, I see you don't care what I did as well i couldn't
make it no but i distracted the flame throw guys long enough
he fucking he doesn't he fucking killed me oh i held i held
on to them my last bullet in her head oh my god i can't i'm
so proud of europe here Oh, thank God.
Very job.
Thank you.
Spaceship Prime.
Only gets it down, you know.
The one hell diver that got extracted.
The one true.
How many side missions I've done that...
You didn't do all of them.
Because someone decided to...
What happened to your teammates?
What teammates?
I went in alone.
What do you mean?
Hey, we got four stars, though.
We got four stars.
You're total victory.
last fight felt like teamwork at the end there you know what
i'm saying i know that was like a team team play right there
oh yeah yeah there's definitely so much teamwork going on
well on our end yeah i don't know yeah i did nothing for the
team at all yeah my bad we did the main objective we got the
we did the main objective that progressed the game look at
this dude look at this one guy look at you guys dead on the
side don't talk to me talk about the stats man oh how are
you consistently doing so much team damage i don't know i
don't know i tried not to he died eight times again you got
shots look at your shots fired too they correlate with
friendly But I say I have better accuracy than you.
I mean, if you're shooting us, yeah, your accuracy is higher
because you're shooting us.
Hell no.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What's crazy, bro?
We did it, guys.
You're literally 10 kills above me.
We've like tripled the fucking shots.
To finish this mission, we have to do this.
wait okay okay sellers there come over here you need to
upgrade your gear come over here oh yeah you guys have been
good gear and you guys are trying to compare to me go to
strategy them and buy stuff what should I buy oh my god
there's anti-tank I'm gonna buy anti-tank anti-tank I had a
50 friendly fire damage it was me hatcheting don't you no
wait they have flame throwers wait i can have anti-personnel
minefield does it like oh that sounds horrible does it
affect you guys yes it does it affect wow i'm gonna buy it
i'm gonna oh boy it's okay i'll buy the anti-personnel tied
tank.
I'll help.
We're the normal ones here.
I'm helping.
We're ready.
Wait, hold on.
Let me cook.
Wait, I got this one.
Wait, there's a flamethrower?
Wait, I want a flamethrower.
Where is that?
Oh, I'm too...
Yeah, you're not allowed to have one.
It's level 10.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me cook to have a board.
Nothing there, you know.
You have 24 seconds.
Shit.
buy bro what am i gonna buy buy the mine anti-personnel mine
okay we're good we're good we're good what anti-personnel
mine yeah it's the mine oh no that's a no that's gonna kill
us all bro look at the mine that's gonna kill us all what do
you mean no it won't believe in yourself i have a grenade
launcher though i might use the grenade launcher but this is
so expensive 6 000 bucks bro Ah, you'll have enough.
You'll have enough.
We made a lot of money.
No, we did not.
Well, we're supposed to have made a lot of money.
I was able to buy like three things.
Where were you spending your money on Zeller?
How about how about orbital.
Orbital.
How about orbital.
Oh, no.
Eagle cluster bomb seems pretty cool.
I worry about Zeller having more and more powerful weapons
to use.
That's so good.
so good oh eagle napalm airstrike i'm getting this one oh no
oh no i want to choose my helmet all right we're so doomed
okay how do i buy stuff again is in the armory i press r r i
need a gun as well oh okay uh what how much metals do i have
bro i don't even have anything oh war bonds uh 37 you have
to buy everything to unlock it yeah all right Move.
Wait.
That drip kind of go crazy.
Expendable anti-tank one, right?
This one, can you destroy turrets with it?
Can I unlock the homepage?
I think so, right?
Oh my god, I got finger guns!
Guys, we have to be...
I would say like a smaller armored things.
What the fuck is a finger gun?
You get the shit?
We got...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got finger guns.
That's my victory pose.
That's cheating.
Well, you press R.
are this is literally in the battle pass oh you bought a
battle pass no it's free it's a free battle pass you're
supposed to use it to get better weapons press r press r and
then the plus on hell diver hell divers mobilize you buy
guns here and stuff let's see oh oh shit i can claim every
thing fuck oh my god do i unlock page three i unlock page
three oh my god i have a new helmet but i can have a orange
cape so you know who i am let's go i guess i'm gonna save up
for this famine enhancement that was pretty good yeah you're
kind of lacking in that department yeah look at my orange
cape guys
now leave me my cape is orange her cape is orange my cape is
orange i mean look at me compared to zeller oh you know i'm
the richer one don't come here but you paid you paid real
money i looked like i came out of star wars you you're a
super citizen you paid no wait why is my title from the
truth.
Try to hide the shame !
No, no no, no.
Look, look, look, look Like, I have a better title.
I have a better title.
Super sheaf, prime.
I'm a super sheaf prime.
Super sheaf.
Which
you're stealing from smaller streamers now that's kind of
lame what do you mean you you've been streaming longer than
me i started two weeks ago okay yeah yeah two two weeks ago
yeah and i don't even you're still a big streamer though and
i'm a stream either man wow wait what's your what's your
twitch channel twitch.tv yeah guys do you twitch prime there
no don't worry about it don't worry about it I don't stream.
Wait, where's my...
Where's the one I got?
Look, now I have two orbital attacks.
Easy win.
Okay, for this one, we're going to be destroying
fabricators.
So we need to have all the destruction that we could
possibly get.
Hell yeah, leave it to me, bro.
I got two.
I got Eagle Cluster.
I got the better Eagle Cluster, so...
It's not a competition, man.
Hell yeah, it is.
Now it is.
No.
well you have two two clusters that sounds yeah extremely
promising should know it's gonna die uh three and i both
have ego clusters yeah it's great what can go wrong boom
boom boom boom boom
all right let's destroy oh there's already one there orange
key if i didn't destroy any active four holy holy why
they're ready here yo there's a lot oh careful careful
careful wait that's not what i wanted shoot the guys back
shoot the guys back oh i need to grab my gun i need to grab
my anti-personnel wait what do we who the fuck activated the
patrol okay wasn't me grabbing my anti-personnel i can
destroy purple see you guys all right oh are we spawning
this shit i'm waiting for my i got me machine gun oh what is
that why there's so many of them just just run to where
honey's running i got you guys i miss yeah it don't really
seem like you caught us it's okay i actually i actually
caught us and i i got you guys this time oh i hit it nice i
did i did it i did i'm heading back She says that as she
keeps running in the opposite direction of where she's
supposed to run.
I'm coming over now!
I'm heading over now.
Look, it's the end result, not the journey.
Oh, shit.
I thought it's the journey that matters, not the end result.
No, it's the end result that matters.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm heading over, I'm heading over.
My stamina is not as great right now.
Land mine!
Let me pop the ship off to the west.
All right.
Wait, I'm going to go.
up where are you going wait there's trenches here side side
mission oh whoa whoa something hit me something fucking
there's artillery there's artillery hitting me careful
careful careful i'm coming over i'm going over wait we have
turrets here we have turrets here we can use this there's
turrets here yeah i'm gonna get the turrets we got 10
minutes i don't know if these tarts are really gonna be that
useful okay they're not that useful they're not that useful
i'm heading over to hunt yeah i'm heading over to hunt oh
god uh i don't know if you want to come towards me yeah
There's so many of them here.
Leave me.
It's time to go solo.
No, don't go solo.
I don't need you anymore.
Axel and Doki stick together and finish that one.
I'm gonna finish one here.
There's a rail gun here.
There's a rail gun on me.
Okay, I cannot.
Oh, get away.
I'm sure nothing can go wrong if you guys are together,
right?
I got the big, I got the big one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have one stim left.
Everything's fine.
Oh, hey.
Oh, no.
Zeller and Doki, you guys stick together.
Han you you get the one and I get the one and then we'll
maybe get all of them in 10 minutes I'm gonna go north Oh my
god Oh my god There's so many people
Huh?
Oh shit yeah yeah I gotta I gotta like send you back in eh?
Alright get your bitch ass back in I can't see shit!
Get your bitch ass back in here i'm here don't worry i have
my shotgun i can throw a galley gun for us oh yeah that's
like northwards yeah i got you i got you silly yo let's go
go go go go go oh wait is that a tank no it's not good are
we good let's go purple pink i think so purple pink i don't
oh yeah yeah we had it we had Zeller and I heading over.
We're here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We heading over.
We headed over.
I should grab it.
I'm chilling here, guys.
Grab a machine gun.
Give me a sec.
Doing great.
Don't need help.
My machine gun's coming over.
In 12 seconds.
You go up there for me, Zeller.
I'm going to grab my machine gun.
Oh, yeah.
You go.
You go grab that, girl.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Whoa.
there's so many of them oh the cannon oh the cannon time for
me to destroy that then i guess where's the cannon oh i see
the cannon leave it to me leave it to me leave it to us we
have we have ego cluster so i got you i got you oh does the
ego cluster even destroy those things i don't know maybe
maybe i didn't throw it far enough maybe you didn't throw it
far don't worry i'm gonna my eagle cluster too oh it's
jammed never mind what do you mean it's a jam never mind
apparently it's one eagle cluster per person oh no okay i'm
getting close leave it to me closer we're getting closer oh
we bounced off i am so stupid saonara oh my god i got you i
got you i got you i got you we did it we broke it nice we
just gotta get out of here i'll ping uh ping south south
south all right we got this oh guys i'm trying to get into
this wait we got it we got it grab zeller gotcha gotcha
we're going okay i'm gonna throw an eagle cluster oh god oh
i couldn't grab it oh no that's okay we have 16.
guys wait like i i'm on a tank fuck i want a tank on I'm on
a tank.
Here I am watching RPR and solo my fucking house.
They're doing everything to me.
They're doing all the unthinkable things.
Nice, nice.
They were doing all unthinkable things to me.
Oh my lord.
We're okay.
I need a resupply.
Word never changes.
I got it.
Got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
We all bunch up together.
Nothing will happen to us, right?
If we all bunch up together.
Nothing bad is going to happen.
All right.
I'm going to...
Wait, wait.
Wait.
I'm going to grab my...
Maybe my sentry gun can do stuff.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Where do we have to go?
Oh, kind of hard.
Wait, I can do an eagle cluster now.
Oh.
There we go.
But do we need it, though?
Do we need that eagle closer?
I don't know, but there's, like, three things going on in
there.
Southwheres, we have five minutes, guys.
Come on.
Five minutes!
Where's the extraction point?
South, south, south.
Okay, okay, okay.
Right on me.
I'm going to start it.
All right, okay.
Raja!
I'm here.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Four minutes, we got to survive.
All right.
We can do that.
I got the fucking...
I got the big boy.
All right, all right.
I threw my gilding thing already.
my i'm gonna grab my anti-tank i got the anti-tank as well
i'll be there in a second okay i have more eagle cluster
don't worry oh no what do you mean all the way away from you
it has been helpful yeah for the other team that's a lie
that is a lie i'm a truth or nothing but a truth that is a
lie oh my gosh Are you okay?
I'll be there in a minute.
Yeah, you see a little dot.
I think it's our PR.
Don't worry.
Zeller and I were defending you.
We're defending you at the point.
We just standing you.
I'm doing great.
We're doing great, guys.
You hear that?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Look, we're killing so many over here.
Oh, my God.
We're killing so many over here.
Look at us.
Wait, I have these anti-personnel.
You guys got any of them stems?
Yeah, I got four stems left.
Can you stim me?
Can one of you stim me?
Where are you?
You're too far, man.
Oh, no.
You're too far.
I think you gotta stim yourself, bro.
I don't have stims.
Say pretty, please.
I've been looking for one.
You're fine.
I'd rather die than beg you for a fucking stim, ducky.
I'd rather fucking die.
I guess you die then.
I guess you die.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
That's a real homie.
I got an achievement for that.
I'm out!
You are special.
Spawn me in.
Look at all the loot!
Wow!
Oh shit!
Can't wait for me!
Oh no!
Ew!
I swear!
It was an accident!
It was an accident please!
Oh god!
No!
It's a revenge!
Why would you kill me?
It's revenge!
They're here, they're here, they're here, they're here!
They're here, they're here!
I want to have some fun too, come on!
Yeah!
Yeah, you want to say I'm so fun?
No, I fear I'll just...
Yeah, we're just having fun.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Wait, I can bring out my galleon.
I'm gonna bring out the Eagle Nepal male strike.
Oh, God, where?
Where?
Right over there, right in the center.
Oh my God!
Eagles, eagle, eagle, eagle strike, eagle strike.
Cog it in, incoming.
Oh, look, look, it's gonna hit the ball.
Look, it's gonna hit the ball.
Look at that!
Oh my God, that was...
So hot.
Holy shit.
We got two.
Fuck, he's killing everyone.
Yeah, yeah, it definitely killed everybody.
You killed yourself.
I told you before him.
Look, look how many I killed.
Look at you go.
Oh yeah.
Okay, Han was one of the people he killed.
He's on the list.
I was behind cover too.
I got the big boy.
Oh, he died.
what the was that for night 15 seconds i got the anti-tank
boy nice
oh where is it oh we're guys coming in five seconds i got
the anti-tank boy oh my goodness the anti-tank boys what
exactly the anti-tank is like one shot Yeah.
Just remove me that.
Yeah.
Oh, it's coming down.
It's coming down.
We have a hole in front of us.
Leave it to me.
Eagle strike right on you.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We have to get it.
We have to get it if it's right on us.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm in.
Oh, God.
I'm running.
This is not real.
Oh, my God.
I'm getting in, I'm getting in!
I'm getting in!
Oh, we did it!
Let's go!
Oh, easiest game in my life.
I'm so stressed.
You need to see that from my...
You need to see that from my pubic.
He said, Eagle Strike.
I got you, bro.
eagle strike and my whole screen turned red from the laser
no i was like i got your eagle strike on you on you did my
whole screen because i was inside the red laser my whole
screen turned red that's what i died someone flipped that
man i can't believe we successfully extracted holy did we
someone clip that shit please holy we actually did it we all
got extracted for once oh my god we should go so good we
should we should lg on bug island i want to go back to bugs
yes we should lg on the bugs what lg last game last game on
the bugs life is good we oh my god let's look at team damage
real quick all right let's look at the squad i think we sort
of know who has the most team damage oh can you guys see my
finger guns heck yeah trust me not me this time oh look when
it would see me 25
It said you killed me.
No, it's a zero friendly fire.
I regret nothing.
It can't be me.
It's a zero friendly fire.
I saw you shoot the rocket.
Yeah, but it didn't hit anybody.
It hit me in the face.
Are you trying to say stats are lying?
Are you trying to say the stats are lying?
Yes.
Whoa.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna be a medic now.
a medic that's gonna be funny yeah i'll have six themes wait
it's not medic if you let heal yourself i'm a medic for me
now where you guys there seller did you buy the the bow pass
stuff you didn't customize your items press r go to r and
then go to click the war bond the first thing you see yeah
and then you just Okay.
Yeah, you can get new health meds.
How do I equip it on?
I look so cool.
Maybe unlock it.
There's like an equip button.
Oh, they look all so ugly.
It's fine.
Oh my god, Doki, you look terrible.
What do you mean?
I'm orange.
Yo, nice cape.
Yeah, look at my cape.
Look at that.
All right, let's go to Erata Prime.
Nice.
Wait, we can now play on Extreme.
We do that.
Maybe we shouldn't.
What can go wrong with them?
Extreme bug's the one with the big one.
They're all pretty big.
What do you mean?
Oh, you haven't seen big.
Oh, what?
Huh?
It's a big bug.
The double B, big bug.
Alright.
LG.
Eagle Strike on your ass is...
That perfect call out you could have done there actually.
It was literally inside of me.
My whole screen turned red.
That's crazy.
Whoa, where are you going?
Whoa, it looks so dusty.
My ego strike.
My...
Alright, ready.
I got everything I need.
up here all right did you put the help on one i forgot we
don't need it we're not it's not like we're on extreme or
anything i kind of panicked because everybody else is ready
and i was the only one who wasn't ready so i clicked ready
because i want to make people the way it's okay we'll just
go with this whole planet with half of the ammo that we're
supposed to run it's all good that'll be Okay.
Find and close any active.
Oh, it's the holes one.
Oh, why do we spawn in front of people?
Oh!
Whoa!
No!
Oh, God.
There's a big one right behind us.
That's an interesting spawn.
Oh, God.
He's still alive.
I'm needing.
Nice.
my god his ass is on fire oh god okay i'm gonna spawn in a
machine gun real fast that's a wonderful idea he died yep i
killed him okay wait there's another one yeah i'll deal with
him rather my machine gun got it show your butt show your
ass should he die like his daddy's daddy's nice
a fucking ordering a machine gun as well.
One second.
One second move.
Oh, there's Sims here.
Wait, need this thing?
I'll need it.
Wait, need what?
I'm needing this door.
There's a door?
It's loot.
The yambo.
Oh, there is a door.
There's a flame trover in here.
Oh, no.
Wait, that's actually really good here, right?
That's good.
Yeah, except for it's good that there's two of them using
it, but yeah, it's great.
No, I'm not using it.
It's Yoki, so I might run fine.
Yeah, don't worry.
You know, she's got that POV.
You or Doki using it is still not good.
What do you mean?
It's content.
Look at this.
No, it's definitely content.
It's not good, though.
Look, I did it.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, no, there's a stalker nest.
Oh, don't worry.
I have flames over.
I'm heading over.
Yeah, run into that nest.
Come on, go, go, go.
I gotta delete that stalker.
We're gonna die.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go, I'm coming, I'm I'm coming over.
Fire is coming.
Don't worry.
We're like on Tatooine.
I'm coming over.
Where's the second son.
Yeah, where's the second son?
How many sons do you have?
What?
That's exactly what I mean.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Big man coming from the back.
Oh shit!
That's great.
Where's Estelle?
Right behind us.
Oh shit.
Oh, you're right.
Okay, if he gets close.
He's tanky.
Oh, yeah.
Let's just- Yeah, let's run.
Let's run.
Let's lead him over to RPR.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the plaque.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
I'm shooting him in the ass.
I'm fucking him in the ass.
Oh, yeah, I'm dead.
I got him.
Look at me.
He's looking at me.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I was- You did it.
You did it, Zeller.
I was a distraction.
But I got him though, didn't I?
Yeah, yeah.
it's good i was a distraction i'm like killing these small
ones it's a big boy why can i not destroy this local rail or
or layer no you got any names i'm okay no i'm not i am not
okay i am not okay right now okay please somebody i can't
see you i just saw her die in her own flame cover there was
like six of them there's a bio titan over where i was
there's a bio titan yeah so lisa pick up my flame floor pick
it up i i am i am getting fucked wait are my landing on my
flame floor yes nice nice nice nice nice
Let's go.
Wait, where is it?
We gotta close more terminate holes.
Where's my flames are?
It's behind you somewhere.
Did you take it?
Nope, I have a railgun.
Oh, I have it.
I have it.
We're actually like, you know, in the desert and we can't
see shit.
We can't see.
Oh, yeah, this is a terrible map.
Holy moly.
This is what garden with an astigmatism looks like.
There's like, wait, there's mosquitoes too?
Oh, don't get bitten.
by one of them you're gonna die if you get me by one over
here in this planet yeah yeah i don't think they have cures
for whatever disease they have here i don't know how many
names can you i got i got you got you yeah i have i spawned
in oh my god nice thanks guys i got you guys it's a fast
travel okay more holes here gotcha okay oh it's blinded i
think Nice.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, I'm reloading.
I'm reloading.
There's one behind you, Han.
There's one.
There's three behind us.
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
Oh, God.
Oh, it's just coming.
Yeah, there's a giant mushroom.
There's so many.
Wait, wait, what the fuck is this fire spitting shit?
I got the spore.
Okay.
I need resupply soon.
I'm running out of flames.
No.
We'll later have a fucking...
Yes, thank you!
I got you!
It's not one's burning alive.
I can hear this breathing.
Yeah, I can hear it.
I hate it for me.
Don't worry about it.
That wasn't my fault.
I can't hit this guy's leg, bro.
It's okay.
I can just burn it.
Oh!
Oh my god.
He hates me.
Okay, I don't have flames.
I'm going to call a resupply.
I got it with the anti-tank.
nice nice nice nice you didn't kill him well nearly just got
rid of his shield i got another one yeah don't worry we have
another anti-tank fuck okay he's dead nice all right all
right yes resupply i got more flames all right i'm good nice
nice nice all right where do we go uh for five more minutes
to get like four more wait five more oh my god too many
symbols oh my god yes addition is really hard okay i'll
split up i'll split up i'm getting west i'm good zeller and
i are coming over to rpr because we think he needs the most
help yeah yeah i'll go on solo that'll be fine i can't
handle my name baby yeah that's why he's han solo and rpr's
r2d2 he needs more than two people with him yeah that's why
there's a two the only thing i need from you guys is your
guys is nades because i'm out of nades leave it to me do i
throw them now throw them in the in the orange holes oh this
one here this one here yeah yeah that one in this one next
to me okay i got you hold on yeah throw in that hole you got
this though in the hole and this one here oh i got this one
i got this one fire in the hole we did it we need one more
got that last one yep i'm going for it
okay that was easy we had bugs yeah i know right there's
nothing against us humans after the after like the robot
orientation missions this is so easy now hell yeah yeah you
guys you guys haven't met a high uh hive queen yet have you
no is there hive queen here oh is it that little slug
looking bitch no it's a four it's like a massive bug like
it's a well they're all it's gigantic yeah it's like it's
like gigantic though wait is there a hive queen in this map
i don't know if one here on let's go kill her then easy yeah
let's kill her i don't know if it will spawn this difficulty
hey more holes here if you guys have mates all right yeah oh
there's
there's a lot of holes here and a lot of big guys guys it's
okay let me land on there so i can grab my flamethrower han
died yep i sacrificed myself it's all right you wanted to
die so you're closer to us when we extraction pretty much
death only brings us closer exactly as friends yeah war
brings us closer Are we coming in?
Where's the big guy?
I spawned you.
Spawned you.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna land on them.
Oh.
I squished one.
Wait, I'm gonna throw one.
Can you guys, uh, plug rolls?
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Push my flamethrower.
Samples.
Nice, nice, nice.
Where the fuck is my flamethrower?
You have two minutes, so it's probably good.
Yep, let's go.
Let's go.
Uh, northeast, northeast.
Punisher.
Oh, there you go.
We're heading over.
I have no more stims.
I have two stims.
I'm running over.
Okay.
Oh, no, I just saw a big guy.
I'm sorry, NET guys.
I'm way behind, guys, but I'm coming over.
All right, we'll look for you.
Oh, there's a big guy right after you.
Maybe I won't look for you.
Oh, shit.
If you walk over here, I'll get rid of him.
Guys, he's...
He's, like, blocking me.
It's okay.
Come up here!
Come up here.
No, the eagle!
No, no, no.
You threw a mate, Tom.
You threw a mate, Tom, on her.
This is the wall of fire.
Now they can't come over.
See?
I'm okay.
I planned that.
Look at how getting burned.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Nothing bad happened to me.
I'm okay.
I don't think we got it in time.
Han, there's a lot of renexus.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
All right.
Oh, there's some coming in right now.
I'm out of ammo, basically.
Thank you.
All right, I'm going to throw a galley.
Up, up, up.
Oh, my God.
They're doing their part.
We're all doing our part.
I'm through my galley.
Galley in.
Fuck, this guy's so tanky.
He's like...
RPR.
Oh, that's a big guy.
Big guy's over to our left.
Thank you.
I killed one of the...
Fuck, these guys are tanky.
We're gonna try and get the flying ones.
Where's the big guy?
Big guy is down, big guys down.
Oh no, never mind, there's another big guy.
What?
He's dead.
I'm stuck.
I'm flame throwing.
It's okay.
We're good.
Reloading.
There's another big guy.
Another big guy.
He's coming to me.
I'm shooting him in the van.
I'm shooting him.
He's burning.
He's breathing.
You hear the weird stuff.
Really?
Where are you at?
Oh, this is a high queen.
Oh, this guy massive.
Wait, is that the high queen?
Yes.
I'm reloading.
It's okay.
I reload.
Oh, what?
What?
Oh, I, I got like, I killed her, I killed her, I killed her,
I killed her.
I got stomped on.
Miles.
I didn't.
What, you killed her?
Yeah, I killed her.
Nice.
Yes.
Oh, these fucking.
And it's like the good kind.
Small crabs ate me.
I don't know that.
We need to call them in, but there's a lot on us.
You know, the destroyers left orbit.
We can't bring us back.
Come here, shut up your shuttles here.
Remember us.
Remember what we did for all of you.
Don't forget about us.
Who megalol?
Are you good, hun?
Don't forget about us.
Who megalol?
Oh my lord.
Oh my god.
Just like, just another day of work, you know, man.
the high queen we saw and i got stepped on it if i hit it
well it's actually called the bile titan but i keep calling
her high queen for some reason i don't believe it it was
like a cannon in her and then as soon as i finish shooting a
cannon in her there's like three little crab looking guys
jumped on my ass and i just died how dare you cannon the
queen how dare you like on me on me my queen My sacrifice
was not in vain.
Four stars.
Woo!
That's 100%.
Nice!
That's almost like a five star.
A mournful victory.
Remember us.
Look how many samples I got us.
Oh my god, I'm the king.
Holy crap.
Holy shit.
Holy moly.
I'm going around in collecting.
Wait, did you, did your badge update RPR on the bottom left?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah.
It's back to super citizen
Why does it keep changing It knows you're from the shame.
Yeah, it can't hide Paid a win Dark Vidal looking ass.
Oh, no no friendly fire damage.
Next one for him is gonna be senior citizen.
We did so good We learned We did it.
I was like fires everybody You guys how are you guys not
fired?
any shots I don't get it I'm shooting big rockets because
we're shooting to kill not shooting right he's shooting big
rockets you're only shooting small rockets I'm shooting like
pellet guns like
GG's guys I had fun that was so fun yeah I'm glad we yeah
thanks for joining me thank you guys I had a lot of fun
doing our parts The favorite game we had for me was the
first one.
What do you mean?
My favorite game was the game before this.
Nah, seeing Zeller land on Han and then pick up his Scarpa
cannon and shoot ducking the ass was 100% a highlight of
this whole thing.
At the very beginning.
Just a duck walk out.
We landed on Zeller too.
There's a one-way land on Zeller next to Han.
Right after, yeah.
GG guys I'm so happy to play Hell Divers too with all of you
It was fun yeah Yeah You guys are so fun with my squad It's
game of hell fun Yeah And I know why you spent 10 hours on
it last night Like holy shit Let's do it again sometime Yeah
Hell yeah for sure GG I'm gonna talk to my chat a little bit
But thank you guys for joining Let's do this again.
Let's salute to the captain.
How do I do the salute?
This is my ship.
I'm actually, it's top left.
This is operated by RPR.
I am the captain.
Let's salute to the captain.
Aye aye.
Oh, he left.
All right.
Bye.
Thanks for having us.
Bye bye.
Destroyer has left squadron.
All right.
Let me swap real quick.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Oh, no, leaks, leaks!
Oh, no, remember, leaks!
I forgot to hide that.
Sorry, guys.
A little bit of a sneak peek for the charity auction for
Saturday.
Oh, that was really fun.
That was so fun.
I'm really happy will play with Hans Zellian RPR today and
it has been a joy to play with the three play with some new
friends today sorry to the ones for the people in NA that I
had to stay up so late for this collab I really do
appreciate for all you guys staying up this late and hanging
out with us and but I had so much fun.
Like I said, they're all, they're all like in Japan at the
moment.
So that's why, like, I wanted to accommodate them.
So I hope you guys had a great time.
Thank you all for the super chance.
Holy shit.
Affiliate and thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
This group was so fun.
Hope you guys get to collab more in the future.
I hope so too.
I definitely had a great time.
Thank you again for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
200 plus dollars trying to get Alzheimer's to to work like
you guys don't understand it was so funny because like he
couldn't get it to work on the first account so we're like
just make a new account and do like family share and then it
didn't work because it's like region locked so that we're
like okay buy like buy steam gift card and then he couldn't
buy steam gift card and it on and it didn't work because
like for some reason he tried multiple times to purchase it
and then the account got locked so then we're like okay hon
you buy the game for him and then and then and then give the
account to zealot and that worked holy shit oh my god it was
like a lot of back and forth it was so funny um but yeah
everybody i'm gonna rest now oh it's been a long long day so
i hope you guys had a fun time watching as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get
that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye